des sujets de désinformation et
d'influence mais aussi les questions
relatives aux effets psychologiques et
sanitaires notamment chez les enfants
nos travaux nous ont également donné
l'occasion d'aborder les sujets relatifs
aux droits d'auteur sur l'ensemble de
ces thèmes monsieur le rapporteur et les
membres de la commission d'enquête qui
le souhaiteront des questions à vous
poser mais je me dois avant de vous
donner la parole pour un bref propos
liminaire si vous le souhaitez pour nous
préciser notamment vos fonctions au sein
de Tik Tok je me dois de vous rappeler
que cette audition est captée qu'elle
est retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et je dois procéder au formalités
d'usage pour les commissions d'enquête
je dois ainsi vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 434 et 434
15 du code pénal et je vous invite à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure
je le jure monsieur Garandeau merci vous
avez la parole pour un petit
introduction luminaire et puis après on
passera aux questions de monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs permettez-moi de me présenter
donc je suis directeur des relations aux
institutionnelles et des affaires
publiques de Tik Tok en France j'ai été
recruté le 7 septembre 2020 après plus
de 20 ans de carrière au service de la
culture de l'innovation du numérique
j'ai rejoint Tik Tok car cette
plateforme apporte une nouvelle culture
une nouvelle écriture audiovisuelle
aussi et une nouvelle génération de
cinéastes avec des codes qui leur sont
propres
c'est aussi une nouvelle manière de
diffuser et de partager des oeuvres et
des moments de vie au profit du plus
grand nombre
musique énergie vitesse joie du partage
dialogue des cultures sur la toile du
monde au fond TikTok nous renvoie aux
Années Folles aux surréalisme à
l'invention du cinématographe Tik Tok et
la minute lumière au format vertical
alors je vous remercie de cette
opportunité qui nous est donné
d'intervenir devant votre commission
nous avons mobilisé l'ensemble de nos
équipes pour répondre avec la plus
grande attention à tous les
questionnaires qui nous ont été adressés
et cette audition permet de répondre
plus directement à vos attentes et à vos
légitimes interrogations
si je peux présenter l'entreprise en
deux mots
Tik Tok a été créé il y a moins de 6 ans
et appartient au groupe by dance limited
fondé en 2012
sa direction opérationnelle et partager
entre Singapour ou résine notre CIO et
les États-Unis à Los Angeles où sont
localisés les centres de décision sur
les opérations enfin c'est à Dublin en
Europe que notre entité dénommée de
trust and safety confiance et sûreté
dotée de 40000 personnes assurent la
sécurité et la protection des
utilisateurs et de leur donner sous le
pilotage global d'un directeur de
nationalité irlandaise
nos priorités n'ont jamais changé
la plus ardente et la sécurité et le
bien-être de nos utilisateurs
ainsi notre politique de traitement des
données vise au plus haut standard de
sécurité elle est fondée sur un principe
clé celui de la souveraineté numérique
qui passe par la localisation des
données au plus près des utilisateurs
avec intervention d'un tiers de
confiance et un recours technologies de
protection les plus avancées
la protection des jeunes utilisateurs
âgés de 13 ans et plus est aussi au
coeur de nos préoccupations ce qui passe
par des fonctionnalités restreintes des
contenus adaptés une limitation du temps
d'écran tout cela en étroite
collaboration avec le monde académique
et les associations spécialisées je
pense notamment en France
la deuxième priorité est devrait au
service de nos utilisateurs et de leur
communauté au plus près c'est la raison
pour laquelle Tic-Toc développe des
équipes locales dans les différents pays
chargés d'accompagner les créateurs les
institutions les marques Marlène masure
cet après-midi
pourra vous en dire bien davantage
enfin pour ma part je suis naturellement
chargé de veiller à ce que Tik Tok
respecte pleine loi les pleinement les
lois et règlements en vigueur
mais aussi l'écosystème propre à la
France pour que le développement de
l'entreprise soit le plus utile possible
à la société française dans toutes ses
composantes de l'éducation à la santé
publique en passant par l'emploi le
tourisme le soutien aux petites et
moyennes entreprises la contribution à
l'information et au débat public ainsi
que rayonnement international de la
France et de ses territoires
mesdames et messieurs je suis à votre
disposition
merci Monsieur le Directeur nous allons
commencer comme d'habitude par des
questions de monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président et merci
Monsieur Garlando d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation
je ne sais pas s'il en est de même pour
vous mais nous nous étions impatients de
vous entendre
impatient et curieux
et notamment pour la raison suivante
lorsqu'on lit les déclarations des
responsables de Tik Tok pas seulement en
France mais dans tous les TikTok du
monde on se rend ou qu'on se rend sur
les sites de Tik Tok il y a un mot qui
revient sans cesse c'est celui de
transparence
je me permets de citer la page d'accueil
de votre site français chez Tik Tok
notre mission est d'inspirer la
créativité et d'apporter la joie nous
sommes passionnés par le fait de gagner
la confiance de notre communauté en
construisant celle-ci de manière
responsable équitable et ouverte
et lorsqu'on interroge beaucoup de
personnes nous avons interrogé beaucoup
de monde depuis le début de ces
commissions d'enquête que ce soit des
régulateurs des journalistes des
ministres des commissaires européens et
bien d'autres le mot qui revient 99 fois
sur 100 c'est celui d'opacité
on peut le résumer par ce passage d'un
article du Monde que vous me permettrez
de citer du 16 janvier 1923
2023 pardon le travail de l'équipe
dirigeante de Tik Tok en France consiste
en réalité à tenter de nettoyer l'image
d'opacité sans perdre en opacité c'est
ainsi qu'en 2020 l'entreprise a recruté
eric Garandeau nommé directeur des
affaires publiques
l'utile entremetteurs joue le monsieur
incendie s'emploie l'évangélisation des
cabinets ministériels et agitent ces
réseaux en tous sens
alors je doute pas que vous ayez
aujourd'hui à coeur de démontrer la
pertinence de la devise de Tik Tok sur
son site et de faire mentir cet article
et l'impression plutôt mitigé qu'il
donne de votre entreprise et que vous
allez nous faire ici une démonstration
de transparent
je voudrais commencer pour que tout le
monde sache de quoi on parle par
l'organigramme de Tik Tok par
l'organisation de Tik Tok France
cette organigramme vous ne l'avez fait
parvenir
et même de façon détaillée
il y manque juste une personne dans
cette organigramme c'est ce c'est la
présidente de Tik Tok France
ça nous a un peu surpris c'est un peu
comme si on vendait l'organigramme de
Facebook et que il y avait pas monsieur
Zuckerberg
alors cette évidemment nous avons pris
d'autres renseignements du côté de Bercy
du côté du tribunal du commerce et nous
nous sommes rendus compte que la
présidente de Tik Tok France
c'est-à-dire celle qui a signé qui a
déposé les statuts qui étaient qui a
déposé au tribunal de commerce qui
enregistré elle s'appelle madame Zao
Thiam
c'est une chinoise une chinoise de Chine
pas une chinoise de France
qui d'ailleurs
a fait ses études à la célèbre académie
diplomatique de Pékin
qui forment les diplomates pas mal de
cadres et puis tout ce qui est para
diplomatique si je peux dire
et
ma première question c'est si vous me
permettez c'est
je trouve un peu dommage de ne pas avoir
joué à cette organigramme la personne
qui dirige juridiquement Tik Tok France
qui est Madame Zaho Tian
monsieur le rapporteur
vous étiez une autre entreprise
ils sont présidents le président de Tik
Tok et connu sa vie de Monsieur chaud
chouchou donc il est tout à fait connu
et il présente régulièrement
l'entreprise s'agissant de Tik Tok SAS
Tik Tok la France nous vous avez en
transmis l'organigramme qui correspond à
l'activité à la réalité de l'activité et
de l'organisation de Tik Tok en France
la plupart des entreprises de la tech y
compris certainement celles que vous
citiez ont des filiales dans tous les
pays du monde et pour des raisons
j'allais dire de faciliter quand vous
devez contenu d'une croissance très
rapide créer des filiales dans le monde
entier la facilité c'est de nommer la
même personne à la tête d'un grand
nombre de filiales pour des raisons
effectivement juridiques puisqu'il faut
avoir un président dans chaque filiale
mais ce sont des personnes qui n'ont pas
de responsabilité opérationnelle
à telle enseigne que je n'ai jamais
rencontré cette personne
je crois d'ailleurs qu'elle est plutôt
canadienne en tout cas de nationalité
canadiennes il me semble
je crois qu'à l'opère sur des sujets de
d'éthique et de d'anthologie mais
absolument pas en France et donc nous ne
l'avons jamais rencontré donc là la
réalité de l'organisation de
l'entreprise c'est je pense cela qui
vous intéresse c'est que nous sommes
organisés en différentes directions
et que chaque responsable de Paul donc
moi-même pour ceux qui concernent les
relations institutionnelles Marlène
masure que vous allez interroger cet
après-midi pour ceux qui concerne la
direction des opérations et des contenus
nous répondons à un supérieur
hiérarchique si on peut dire qui se
trouve être à Londres puisque Tik Tok UK
et la structure c'est un peu notre
maison mère européenne et donc de même
que moi je réponds à Théo Bertram
vice-président en charge des affaires
publiques au niveau européen de même
Harlem masure répond à rich waterworth
qui est
directeur général en charge des contenus
et des opérations pour toute l'Europe et
c'est ainsi que nous fonctionnons et
nous avons un troisième pôle que vous
avez bien vu aussi le pôle Global
Business Services qui travaille pour le
compte d'une troisième division
également située à Londres à tik Toky ok
donc en fait
la personne que vous citiez n'a
absolument aucun rôle opérationnel dans
l'entreprise et nous ne l'avons jamais
rencontré
ce que je ne l'ai jamais rencontré je
peux parler pour moi-même alors une
petite précision vous dites que Madame
zaoutienne et canadienne comme beaucoup
de Chinois et pour des raisons diverses
pris une autre nationalité c'est
toujours plus prudent mais elle est chez
nous là aussi la nationalité canadienne
c'est une première précision vous
comprenez bien que lorsque nous avons
envoyé le questionnaire nous vous avons
demandé un certain nombre de
renseignements sur l'actionnariat etc
d'ailleurs question que sur lesquelles
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui de réponse
mais
que pour nous ce qui est important c'est
tout ça autant le juridique que
l'opérationnel et que nous souhaitions
avoir l'ensemble de l'organigramme de
Tik Tok et qu'il a fallu le chercher
ailleurs
je dois vous dire d'ailleurs que on
était un peu surpris de constater que
Tik Tok France dans le chiffre
d'affaires était de 29 millions d'euros
l'an dernier du doublé au triplet cette
année est une société simplifiée à
actionnaire unique
c'est assez peu fréquent avec quand on
parle de somme de ce montant
de budget de ce montant et donc
juridiquement madame zaoutienne est la
seule habilité à pouvoir prendre toute
décision du genre vendre de la société
acquisition d'autres sociétés fusion etc
et donc elle n'est peut-être pas
opérationnelle mais sur le plan du
devenir de l'entreprise elle joue un
rôle joue un rôle majeur
alors nous avons invité
vous le savez madame zaoutienne à nous
rencontrer ainsi que trois autres
dirigeants de Tik Tok monsieur zotticcio
monsieur tangamine et Monsieur
[Musique]
ils nous ont pas répondu encore je ne
sais pas s'ils ont le temps de venir
nous voir mais effectivement je
comprends que Madame madame zaoutienne
n'est pas le temps de venir nous voir
parce qu'elle fait beaucoup d'autres
choses d'ailleurs c'est ce que vous avez
dit c'est quand même un peu dommage
qu'elle ne vienne pas visiter la France
en étant président directeur général de
Tik Tok France mais enfin bon
elle est également présidente de tik
Tokyo
elle est également au bord de Tik Tok
Australie
mais elle était également
vice-présidente
de tout
alors ça ça pose un problème parce que
je crois que c'est un secret pour
personne vous essayez
désespérément de répondre à l'accusation
permanente que Tik Tok est une société
chinoise ou en tout cas une société où
les le centre de décision se situe en
Chine avec une influence du PC chinois
dans ces instances dirigeantes et vous
dites comme d'ailleurs tous les
présidents ou les directeurs de Tik Tok
en
Occident nous n'avons rien à voir avec
la Chine les entités sont séparées
et nous n'avons rien à voir avec douille
in qui est je le précise parce que ça a
tellement changé au cours des années
précédentes que c'est un véritable entre
lac de société qui est le nouveau nom de
Biden the Shin puisque auparavant
tout Yao est une filiale de
by dancing c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui de
douiller
alors quand vous nous expliquez qu'il
n'y a aucun lien entre
TikTok France contre les TikTok
occidentaux et les entités chinoises je
me permets de vous donner quand on a la
vice-présidente de tout Yao fondé par
gaming et dont madame
c'est
vice-présidente depuis 2015 sont si sur
son site internet il y a quelques temps
à la posté sur son sa page LinkedIn la
posté le fait qu'elle était la puis 8
ans et 3 mois avec un très fier
je vois pas comment on peut dire dans
ces conditions
que on n'a pas de lien avec la partie
chinoise de by dance
monsieur le rapporteur je pense que il
est peut-être utile pour pour
l'auditoire de rappeler l'organisation
du groupe brés dance comme vous l'avez
fait rapidement parce que en matière de
d'organisation juridique du groupe il y
a bien une séparation totale entre Tik
Tok et d'autres entités opérants en
Chine donc ce qui est important de voir
c'est que by dance limited qui est donc
la maison mère
qui est effectivement immatriculée dans
un territoire britannique d'outre-mer
détient à 100% Tik Tok Limited et
qu'ensuite Tic-Toc limited va avoir des
filiales dans les différents territoires
aux États-Unis et en Europe en Europe
nous avons donc Tik Tok UK et Tik Tok
Irlande tik tokylan c'est l'entité qui
va être en charge de opérer la
plateforme d'avoir des relations avec
les utilisateurs et les autorités de
régulation tout ce qui concerne
l'application du rgpd par exemple du DSA
c'est TikTok Irlande Tik Tok UK out
qu'elle opère la plateforme pour les
citoyens britanniques est aussi notre
entité maison mère pour l'Europe dont
Tik Tok SAS France est aussi la filiale
donc vous voyez quand en termes de
d'organisation de verticale du haut en
bas donc de Biden smithid jusqu'à TikTok
SAS on a bien une chaîne qui est
entièrement soumise un droit qui est qui
n'est pas un droit chinois qui est un
droit
conforme dans les différents entités
dans lesquelles ces entités opèrent mais
donc vous n'avez aucun lien avec la
Chine le lien il se fait comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure au niveau de
douille in est une filiale de byt dance
Edwin ensuite détient d'autres filiales
qui opèrent en Chine mais les deux sont
totalement détachés
s'agissant je reviens de de la
présidente de Tik Tok SAS
comme c'est l'usage dans un grand nombre
de d'entreprises technologiques
l'entreprise qui sont présentes dans un
grand nombre de pays dans plus de 80
pays
il est très usuel que les filiales
soient créés j'allais dire à l'appel en
même on en crée des dizaines en même
temps on est obligé et dans ce cas là
par facilité c'est la même personne qui
est présidente de chaque filiale mais ça
n'entraîne aucun lien opérationnel comme
je vous l'indiquais nous n'avons jamais
en tout cas moi je n'ai jamais vu cette
personne ni à l'occasion de mon
recrutement ni par la suite j'étais
recruté par Monsieur théobert tram par
rich waterworth que je citais tout à
l'heure puis par le CEO qui était à
l'époque américain qui s'appelait Kevin
Meyer et cette personne n'est jamais
intervenue et je n'ai jamais vu avoir la
moindre responsabilité dans Tik Tok SAS
quand vous dites que vous ne la voyez
pas avoir la moindre responsabilité je
vous ai quand même indiqué tout à
l'heure qu'elle avait tous les pouvoirs
et peut-être la chaîne à travers la
chaîne de que vous nous avez indiqué
mais tous les pouvoirs sur l'avenir de
Tik Tok sur l'avenir juridique de Tik
Tok
elle peut demain décider de vendre la
société de la dissoudre etc les
actionnaire unique donc je comprends
qu'elle n'ayez jamais vu je le regrette
d'ailleurs mais
elle a des fonctions juridiquement
extrêmement importantes et c'est ça qui
les fonctions sur le contrôle juridique
de la société et par ailleurs vous
m'avez parlé du rôle de l'enchaînement
vertical des sociétés
mais là moi je vous parle de
l'horizontalité cette personne vous
essayez désespérément depuis trois ans
depuis que vous êtes
quelques problèmes aux États-Unis est
désormais en avec l'interdiction de
l'application Tik Tok sur les
smartphones des fonctionnaires vous
essayez des Espérants je le comprends de
dire qu'il n'y a aucun aucun lien entre
voilà entre les deux entités
on verra tout à l'heure d'ailleurs en ce
qui concerne l'opérationnel les
algorithmes etc s'il n'y a vraiment
aucun lien mais vous nous dit qu'il n'y
a aucun lien juridique et nous nous
retrouvons avec une personne qui a des
responsabilités juridiques aussi bien en
Chine
qu'en France ou que dans d'autres pays
vous comprenez bien que ça pose un
problème quand même et que le discours
qui consiste à se dire on a on a aucun
lien
il est quand même difficile à tenir
monsieur rapporteur vous disiez tout à
l'heure l'actionnariat Tik Tok et SAS
est détenu par Tic-Toc
UK qui est lui-même détenu par Tik Tok
limited si lui-même détenu par Biden
limited nous avons un CIO qui est
Monsieur chouchou
c'est lui le CEO de Tik Tok et ensuite
vous avez des chaînes opérationnelles
qui redescendent avec d'un côté les
relations publiques le marketing les
fonctions commerciales et tout cela
redescend jusqu'à jusqu'à la France donc
c'est cela la chaîne du pouvoir la
chaîne hiérarchique et c'est ainsi que
notre groupe est organisé la fonction de
présidente est une fonction purement
formelle elle n'a pas de n'a aucun
aucune conséquence opérationnelle
on est bien d'accord
elle n'a pas de conséquence dans la
manière dont l'entreprise dont le groupe
est dirigé et je veux peut-être aussi
rajouter quelque chose c'est que
indépendamment de cette organisation
juridique nous avons évidemment mis en
place toute une série de contrôles s'il
s'agit je comprends que la préoccupation
légitime porte sur la sécurité des
données des utilisateurs notamment des
utilisateurs européens et bien sachez
que nous avons aussi mis en place de
manière technique des systèmes qui
permettent d'éviter toute forme
d'intrusion d'ingérence et et cela passe
notamment par le projet que vous
connaissez je pense le projet Clover qui
consiste à créer en Europe des centres
de données qui seront sécurisés par une
entité tierce qui ne sera pas TikTok
mais qui sera une entité européenne
et de manière à ce que les données des
utilisateurs européens soient pleinement
protégées c'est un investissement d'un
milliard 200 millions d'euros par an et
qui précisément à éviter
non seulement toute critique mais tout
risque d'intrusion non désirée nous
mettons aussi en place des des contrôles
de sécurité de manière à ce que un
nombre limité de personnes est accès à
ces centres de données et de manière à
ce que toute accès extérieur soit aussi
le minimum rendu au minimum possible
c'est à dire le minimum qui consiste à
assurer le fonctionnement de la
plateforme
nous recourons aussi comme je disais
dans l'Introduction à des technologies
de protection les plus avancées en
matière d'inscription en matière
d'anonymisation de pseudo
pseudonymisation des données
d'agrégation pour aussi éviter tout
risque donc voilà c'est important de
mentionner d'une part l'organisation du
groupe qui est encore une fois n'a que
des entités de droits international et
qui n'est jamais soumis aux droits
chinois et ensuite un système technique
robuste et en même temps sophistiqué
très avancé et enfin comme je pense que
vous avez aussi un souci légitime sur la
les contenus qui peuvent circuler sur la
plateforme nous avons cette entité très
statistique et comme je le disais est
dirigée par un irlandais en Irlande
40000 personnes qui sont évidemment
répartis aussi dans d'autres pays
notamment à Singapour et aux États-Unis
et cette entité va être en charge de
faire respecter les règles
communautaires de Tik Tok et ces règles
interdisent toute tentatives de
désinformation de manipulation de
l'opinion de porter atteinte à
l'intégrité d'une élection et vous avez
donc un très grand nombre de modérateurs
qui vont intervenir ainsi que des tiers
de confiance l'AFP
pour faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas
assez risque là donc vous voyez la
question que vous posez c'est de la
réponse que nous apportons c'est que
quel que soit la nationalité des
personnes le système soit suffisamment
robuste et sophistiqué pour empêcher
tout intrusion tout ingérence et toute
manipulation de l'information oui je
crois qu'on parle pas exactement la même
langue je vous parle juridique vous me
répondez opérationnel je suis tout à
fait prêt à entendre des choses sur
l'opérationnel et c'est ce que nous
allons voir tout à l'heure mais pour le
moment je commence par le juridique et
par l'organisation des sociétés Tik Tok
et by dance
vous nous dites vous venez d'employer
les mots aucune de ces entités n'est
jamais soumise au droit chinois
depuis et je trouve que la présidente
Duke comme celle de Tiko France c'est
Madame Diao qui est une ressentissante
chinoise
avec tout ce qui est toutes les
conséquences puisque c'est vous avez
peut-être me le dire TikTok sur l'action
narratique là mais je vais pas détecter
mais je vais pas en parler tout de suite
elle peut donc prendre les décisions
juridiques essentielles pour une pour
votre société depuis les deux lois
chinoises de 2017 et 2019 tout citoyen
est toute société chinoise chinoise
est tenu de collaborer avec les
autorités d'ailleurs c'était comme ça
avant mais c'était pas dans le droit
c'était pas encore inscrit
aussi bien en matière de renseignement
qu'en matière que que dans différentes
hautes matières ce sujet a fait couler
pas mal d'angle mais il y a un sujet
dont on a moins parlé c'est que en même
temps que le gouvernement chinois a pris
ces deux décisions c'est de loi qui est
désormais s'applique et qui d'ailleurs
dont Monsieur Jack ma ou Monsieur Jack
gaming on parlera tout à l'heure
pourrait sans doute nous dire pas mal de
choses désagréables
le gouvernement chinois a pris désormais
la décision que son droit s'appliquait
de façon extraterritoriale c'est-à-dire
que tous les Chinois non seulement en
Chine mais même à l'extérieur de la
Chine sont tenus de déférer
dans référent au gouvernement chinois
pour des raisons sur des domaines de
renseignement ou c'est des domaines
différents vous avez donc une société
tiktas France une société TikTok
UK limite présider par une
présidente chinoise qui a des pouvoirs
dont on a parlé à l'instant et qui
par l'extraterritorialité du droit
chinois aujourd'hui est obligé si le
gouvernement chinois le décide dans une
comment pourrait-on dire d'obéir aux
injonctions du gouvernement chinois je
dis je veux dire que j'ai du mal à
comprendre comment dans ce contexte
ou
vous avez ces accusations dont on
parlait tout à l'heure qui ont commencé
aux Etats-Unis et où vous essayez
désespérément de
d'expliquer que vous n'avez rien à voir
avec la Chine
je dois dire que je comprends pas
comment vous avez décidé de nommer une
présidente chinoise dont vous dites
qu'elle n'a strictement aucun rôle
opérationnel vous auriez pu aussi me
reprendre monsieur Dupont ça aurait été
moins
ennuyeux parce qu'aujourd'hui nous nous
retrouvons avec cette question le
président de chinoise de deux sociétés
et d'autres d'ailleurs
extraterritorialité du droit chinois et
difficulté d'expliquer quand même qu'il
y a pas une certaine présidente de tout
Yao vice-président de tout Yao pardon
donc d'une société chinoise c'est quand
même difficile d'expliquer que cette
dame même si vous l'avez jamais vu c'est
jamais vu des pieds en France ne peut
pas y compris de Singapour où elle
habite aujourd'hui je crois prendre des
décisions qui seraient
disons pour employer un mot une litote
inspiré par au sujet par le gouvernement
chinois
monsieur le rapporteur je pense qu'il
faut peut-être revenir vous parler de
juridique donc effectivement en termes
de droits des sociétés comme je disais
il y a un empilement donc Tic-Toc SAS
tik Toky Tik Tok Limited et by dance
donc la le pouvoir il descend à 100%
jusqu'en bas depuis le conseil
d'administration de la maison mère qui
est donc Biden Limited et qui n'est
encore une fois pas soumis au droit
chinois qui sont les membres du conseil
d'administration et qui sont d'ailleurs
les apporteurs de capital et au groupe
bin dance vous avez Bill Ford qui
représente générale Atlantique donc un
fond d'investissement institutionnel
américain vous avez Arthur dans le chic
qui représente sous ski Anna qui est un
autre fond d'investissement
institutionnel américain vous avez
Philippe Lafon qui est français c'est
intéressant de mentionner vous avez un
des cinq membres du conseil
d'administration de bydensky et français
et qui
intervient au nom de quoi tu es qui est
son fonds d'investissement et puis vous
avez ni chaîne qui intervient au nom de
séquoia qui est un autre fond dans
l'investissement et enfin rubollyang qui
est le président de by dance donc c'est
là qui est le pouvoir de by dance qui
comme j'expliquais descend jusqu'en bas
jusqu'à Tik Tok SAS
donc vous voyez bien je pense que
c'est personne et ces entités qui
représentent 60% aujourd'hui du capital
de bindens ce sont eux qui exercent le
pouvoir et ensuite pouvoir redescendre
jusqu'à la filiale pour être exhaustif
20% du capital à partir au fondateur qui
est donc
et puis 20% restants appartiennent aux
salariés du groupe ainsi qu'à des petits
actionnaires donc voilà je pense que
c'est ça la réalité de pouvoir qui est
exercée et ensuite le fait qu'il y ait
tel ou telle personne dans les filiales
encore une fois c'est quelque chose qui
se fait dans la plupart des des
entreprises multinationales qui pour des
raisons de facilité et parce
qu'effectivement le droit l’oblige dans
chaque pays ont des personnes qui sont
souvent les mêmes personnes mais qui
n'ont absolument aucun rôle opérationnel
merci de cette de cette réponse mais qui
ne à mon avis ne correspond pas vraiment
à la question alors si vous voulez que
je réponde peut-être à la question de la
nationalité puisque
et la question d'extraterritorielle du
de les lois chinoises tout ce que nous
avons mis en place vice précisément à
éviter la moindre critique le moindre
risque quel que soit la nationalité des
personnes de quelques gouvernements que
ce soit de quelques nationalités que ce
soit nous mettons en place un système
qui permet par son intégrité par sa
robustesse par le fait que nous avons
des tirs de confiance qui vont assurer
la cybersécurité de ces centres de
données
par le fait que nous avons de très
grandes équipes de modérateurs des
contenus qui interviennent encore une
fois dans toutes les langues ils
interviennent dans plus de 70 langues
nous avons 600 modérateurs par exemple
en langue française donc toutes ces
mesures sont faites pour que quel que
soit la nationalité quelle que soit le
gouvernement nous n'ayons pas de risque
d'intrusion de risques de porter
atteinte à l'intégrité de la plateforme
pour nous c'est cela qui est vraiment
important et nous sommes l'entreprise je
pense la plus avancée ou une des plus
avancées en la matière le fait de
décider d'investir un milliard 500
millions de dollars aux États-Unis pour
construire des centres de données
sécurisés et par Oracle donc puisque ces
données sont même opérées directement
par Oracle dans une entité dédiée qui
s'appelle usds avec 1000 personnes
justement de américaine qui
interviennent le fait que nous ayons à
la fois Oracle et un tiers de confiance
supplémentaire qui valide chaque
modification du code source chaque
actualisation du code de Tik Tok
lorsqu'il est envoyé dans les magasins
d'applications
dans les App Store et vérifier à la fois
par Oracle et par ce deuxième tiers de
confiance donc tout cela assure
l'impossibilité pour quiconque quel que
soit sa nationalité
fut-elle chinoise de pouvoir porter
atteinte à ce dispositif et d'ailleurs
les utilisateurs européens bénéficient
de ce système puisque c'est la même
application c'est le même code source en
fait qui est injecté aux États-Unis qui
permet à tout un chacun de télécharger
Tik Tok dans le monde entier et c'est ce
projet cette démarche que nous sommes en
train aussi d'appliquer en Europe à
travers le projet Clover nous avons
construit un premier Data Center à
Dublin nous en avons construit nous
construisons un deuxième vous ne l'avez
déjà dit et puis ce n'est pas vraiment
ma question vous comprenez si vous me
permettez je comprends enfin j'essaie de
répondre à votre légitimateur
en montrant que c'est la robustesse d'un
système c'est le fait de passer par des
tiers de confiance qui ne sont pas Tik
Tok et qui pourront justement vous
apporter cette assurance de la même
façon si nous soumettons ce dispositif
avec des centres données des construits
en Europe qui sont sécurisés par un
tiers de confiance européen si nous
demandons à Annecy de pouvoir aussi
vérifier auditer ce dispositif c'est je
pense la meilleure façon de répondre à
cette légitime préoccupation et vous
parlez de la Chine mais on peut parler
d'autres pays la Chine n'est pas le seul
pays qui peut avoir envie de faire des
intrusions lorsqu'il y a eu la guerre en
Ukraine nous avons aussi pris des
mesures très fortes nous avons recruté
des modérateurs dans les deux langues
ukrainiens et russes pour pouvoir nous
assurer que personne ne porterait
atteinte à l'intégrité de la plateforme
ou ne diffuserait des fausses
informations nous avons d'ailleurs été
le la première plateforme à interdire
l'accès à
Spoutnik et à rue Châteaudun donc on a
on a même labell les comptes de médias
détenus par des états vous voyez qu'ils
soient chinois russe ou de toute
nationalité pour que nos utilisateurs
sachent que lorsqu'ils regardent un
compte contre les paraméta qu'il sache
ce que ça veut dire et qui puisse
contrôler vérifier avec des sources
d'information on va dire plus
indépendantes donc nous faisons ce
travail permanent
pour nous améliorer on va venir aux
questions de de contrôle de
l'information etc on va essayer de
Serrier les de serrer les sujets
je vais essayer de revenir sur la
première partie effectivement si à
chaque fois qu'on parle actionnariat
juridique et tout vous parlez
opérationnel l'audition risque d'être un
peu longue
mais effectivement comme le dit le
président les sujets dont vous parlez à
l'instant sont des sujets différents
dont on parlera plus tard
je reviens à ce que vous disiez sur
l'actionnariat puisque vous parlez de
l'actionnariat de by dance caïman
au passage je voudrais vous poser une
question les
îles Caïmans sont classées deuxième au
classement 2021 des paradis fiscaux du
réseau international pour la justice les
îles Caïmans sont l'un des grands
paradis fiscaux du monde qui abritent
évidemment de nombreuses sociétés
offshore en tant que société écran
se déclarait transparent en établissant
son siège dans le paradis des sociétés
écran
c'est une sorte d'oxymore non
il me semble que votre souci encore une
fois légitime c'est que il n'y ait pas
de pression exercée par un état sur Tik
Tok sur cette plateforme importante et
le fait de n'être mis en Chine ni
d'ailleurs aux États-Unis c'est plutôt
en tout cas de ce point de vue là une
sécurité les îles Caïmans sont un
territoire britannique d'outre-mer
soumis au système de Westminster voilà
j'ai pas d'autres commentaires à faire
il y a pas de pression fiscale
ça c'est certain il me semble que vous
intéresser aux pression politique mais
pour s'agissant de on peut tout faire
on pourra en dire un mot même si je
serai un peu limité par le secret fiscal
mais je serais ravi d'échanger à ce
sujet d'ailleurs vous avez pris des
précautions aussi aux États-Unis puisque
Tik Tok Etats-Unis est enregistré au
delawar qui est comme chacun sait à peu
près le même paradis fiscal que les îles
Caïmans mais c'est pour moi relativement
secondaire alors vous nous parliez de
l'actionnariat
et cette actionnariat vous le vous le
brandissez en tout cas Tik Tok
le États-Unis ou baidens pardon le
brandit sur son site avec tous les tous
les grands fonds
qui sont sécurisent la chose évidemment
qui ont investi des milliards de dollars
dans
dans le
dans l'entreprise
mais
et vous nous avez cité
les membres du bord et notamment
monsieur Roubaud Lyon et monsieur
nilschen qui joue le signal au passage
ont le même problème que Madame
zaoutienne du point de juridique c'est
qu'ils sont chinois et qu'avec
l'explorateur idéal il risque un jour ou
l'autre d'avoir quelques contacts de la
part du gouvernement chinois
donc le président de baitet Down c'est
un CHINOIS
il a de nationalité chinoise et donc
sujet au droit chinois
moi ce qui m'intéresse dans
l'actionnariat ça n'est pas le
pourcentage des parts détenus par chacun
des actionnaires ce sont
les droits de vote
comme disait Staline ce qui compte ce
n'est pas les votes c'est qui contre les
votes
Biden ce Cayman est une société
une veille une vallée
c'est-à-dire que les droits de vote ne
correspondent pas aux parts des tenues
par les différents actionnaires
et par conséquent alors vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que les fondateurs
avaient 20% du capital
d'abord déjà sur la répartition du
capital
il se trouve que en France Monsieur
Djang gaming est actionné et
bénéficiaire à 26%. c'est ce qui est
inscrit au tribunal de commerce pourquoi
est-ce que monsieur tsanging est le seul
qui apparaissent auprès du tribunal de
commerce parce que les bénéficiaires
doivent être inscrits à partir de 25%.
mais
les monsieur John gaming ayant 26%
est donc inscrire un commerce il y en a
sans doute mais ils ne sont pas inscrits
j'imagine en remontant la chaîne que si
Monsieur Tsang gaming est bénéficiaire à
26% de Tik Tok SAS France c'est que il
est actionnaire à 26% de
[Musique]
mais je peux me tromper vous allez nous
allez nous le dire alors moi je voulais
vous demander si vous pouvez nous dire
d'une part quelle est la part vous avez
commencé à nous le dire en disant 20%
mais ce n'est pas tout à fait exact
jusqu'à lui seul monsieur de Jean
gimming à 26 %, donc et il est pas le
seul fondateur
si vous pouvez nous dire quelle est la
part des fonde d'investissement général
des fondateurs et des salariés et
éventuellement le nom des salariés parce
que c'est pas c'est pas le développeur
de base qui est dans le qui est dans le
l'actionnariat c'est évidemment quelques
cadres salariés donc ce serait
intéressant de le savoir mais
deuxièmement ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup
plus c'est de savoir quelle est la
répartition des droits de vote parce que
c'est
comme ça qu'on prend la décision de
l'entreprise et dans les vies le système
chinois qui est développé depuis
quelques années c'est comme ça que un
certain nombre d'actionnaires de de
Tencent se sont réveillés avec quelques
douleurs quand ils sont
c'est une société non cotée donc c'est
ce qui explique que
ne publie pas toutes les données que
publie des sociétés cotées qui sont
elles soumises à des obligations de
publication plus importante
par ailleurs ce sont des données que je
n'ai pas ma possession je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on puisse les partager
publiquement dans cette séance mais je
me permettrais en tout cas de revenir
vers vous
voilà sous forme probablement écrite à
ce sujet
si vous me permettez
nous l'avions déjà demandé dans les
questions écrites
bien entendu mais vous auriez eu le
temps de les demander
[Musique]
je voulais vous poser quelques questions
sur monsieur de sanguin
le fondateur de Tik Tok le fondateur de
bindens
qui est donc à ma connaissance en tout
cas selon ce qu'on peut retrouver
actionnaire à 26% de vaidan c'est je ne
sais pas quels sont ces droits de vote
ni ceux de Monsieur robot Lyon
monsieur jean-guyming
était le l'actionnaire quasi unique de
Biden Chine
il a
cédé
38 ans 36 ans
brusquement je crois que c'était en 2021
qui était toutes ses fonctions de
direction à baidenshin qui est devenu
ensuite douillet
au même moment où Jack m'a et un certain
nombre d'autres se faisait
le même genre de situation et
visiblement directement espéré par le
gouvernement chinois mais en ce qui
concerne un gaming je n'en sais rien
et en janvier 2023 monsieur jean-guimi
après avoir donc
quitter toutes ces fonctions
opérationnelles en 2021
à cédé toutes ses parts d'un seul coup
99% de l'entreprise
à une autre société
cette société
qui s'appelle xxq
[Musique]
elle avait été créée 15 jours avant
elle a racheté une entreprise qui va
aujourd'hui quelques centaines de
milliards
puisque douille est l'essentiel TikTok
USA c'est 150 millions de d'utilisateurs
français 15 ou 20 millions
c'est 700 millions donc c'est là le
principal revenu de de Bin dance
il a cédé sépare
à une société qui s'appelle xxq
et qui était détenu à 55 ans par deux
personnes qui s'appelle monsieur yinping
et Monsieur li Ying
en général dans le monde de la tech tout
le monde a une grande visibilité sur des
sites personnels sur Linkedin ou
ailleurs mais ces deux personnes là sont
absolument introuvables sur l'Internet
tout ce qu'on en sait c'est que Monsieur
leasing est un cadre local du PC à
sciamen puisque xxq veut dire que c'est
la ville de Siemen
et Siemen c'est
la ville
en Chine dans le fujiang
dont Monsieur xinking a été
le maire où il a démarré sa carrière
politique dans le fujihane dans les
années 88 90
[Musique]
cette société avait un capital je crois
d'environ 150000 euros elle a racheté
une société qui avait je ne connais pas
son capital tel qu'il est estimé mais
enfin qui a une surface de qui se compte
en centaines de millions ou en milliards
de dollars
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
je n'ai pas connaissance de ce que vous
indiquez je n'avais pas commenter ce qui
me semble très loin de
à la fois de mon rôle de directeur des
relations institutionnelle de Tik Tok
France ni même assez loin de ce Tik Tok
en réalité
ce que je sais simplement c'est que
effectivement notre enfin le fondateur
de by dance donc monsieur iminsang a
quitté c'est fonction opérationnelle je
vois même qu'on vous a envoyé le message
qui est qu'il avait pu envoyer à tous
les salariés du groupe à cette occasion
et qui dans lequel il indiquait qu'il
souhaitait quitter ses fonctions
opérationnelles qui étaient extrêmement
prenante et que il voulait consacrer son
temps à réfléchir à la stratégie du
groupe puisque c'est un fondateur un
entrepreneur visionnaire et qui et qui
pense au long terme et qui donc voulait
se dégager de la gestion quotidienne de
ce groupe voilà ça c'est ce que je sais
ce que je peux vous dire
après si vous souhaitez qu'on puisse
apporter plus de précisions par écrit
sur ce que vous venez d'indiquer nous le
ferons bien volontiers ça m'intéresse
quand même parce que Monsieur djangimin
il est pas du tout son relation il est
pas du tout resté en Chine et tout il
est toujours aujourd'hui à 26 %
apparemment
actionnaire de Biden Skyland et
peut-être même qu'il a la majorité des
droits de vote je n'en sais rien puisque
cette veille a l'air très très difficile
à ausculter donc ça effectivement
j'aimerais savoir quelle est la
répartition des droits de vote et que
quelle est la part de monsieur John
gaming parce que là on a quand même une
relation avec Tik Tok avec Tik Tok
caïman et avec tous les TikTok
UK France etc Monsieur Jean gaming il
avait eu quelques problèmes avec le
Parti communiste chinois lorsqu'il était
PDG de bayden se Chine devenu Douine et
notamment il était également PDG de tout
Yao dans Madame
est aujourd'hui vice-président
il a eu le malheur de faire un site
parodique un peu genre Canard Enchaîné
ce qui pose assez peu de problèmes en
France mais qui généralement peut
évidemment conduire à quelques
difficultés en Chine et donc il s'est
fait il s'est fait taper sur les doigts
et voilà ce qu'il dit dans une
autocritique qui évidemment lui a été
dictée dans le plus pur style maoïste
auquel on est en train de revenir en
Chine
il n'a fait publiquement bien entendu
sur et sur son site j'exprime mes plus
sincère excuse aux autorités à nos
usagers et à mes collègues depuis que
j'ai reçu hier la note des autorités de
régulation je suis plein de remords et
de culpabilité qui m'ont empêché de
dormir tout Yao fermera définitivement
son application Nyan douanese
notre produit a pris un mauvais chemin
et à proposer un contenu incompatible
avec les valeurs de base du socialisme
nous n'avons pas été assez attentif et
n'avons pas assez mis l'accent sur la
responsabilité sociale de l'entreprise
dans la promotion d'une énergie positive
et la compréhension des principes
corrects qui doivent guider l'opinion
publique en tant que start-up en
développement rapide dans le siège du
XVIIIe congrès national du Parti
communiste chinois nous sommes
pleinement conscients que ce
développement a été permis par ces
terres glorieuses j'exprime mes
remerciements pour cet air j'exprime ma
gratitude pour cette occasion historique
de réforme économique et d'ouverture et
ma gratitude envers ce gouvernement qui
a permis le développement de l'industrie
technologique
et il conclut en prenant des engagements
premièrement renforcer le travail de
construction du parti au sein de
l'entreprise réussir l'éducation de
toute notre équipe quand aux quatre
consciences aux valeurs de base du
socialisme au principe qui guident le
pignon public aux lois et règlement pour
agir vraiment dans le sens de la
responsabilité sociale de l'entreprise
approfondir la coopération avec les
médias officiels augmenter la diffusion
des contenus officiels et s'assurer que
la voix des médias officiels soit reliée
avec force renforcer le système de
responsabilité de la rédaction en chef
corrigé entièrement les déficiences dans
le contrôle des algorithmes et des
ordinateurs dans le contrôle des
algorithmes et des ordinateurs renforcer
les opérations et les contrôles humains
alors monsieur John gaming est
aujourd'hui
actionnaire à 26% de Biden ce caïman
peut-être décisionnaire en matière de
droit de vote je n'en sais rien
mais avec Monsieur Roubaud Lyon qui est
le co-fondateur et en 2012 il doit avoir
eu deux sans doute la majorité des
droits de vote ils sont soumises à
l'extralité du droit chinois et ils ont
été en 2018 je crois par cette
autocritique exprimée leur
volonté de se conformer très strictement
à la loi chinoise et à ce que leur
demanderait le Parti communiste chinois
ça fait un peu tâche dans une société
mondiale comme Biden ce qui est aux îles
Caïmans et qui sont et qui est censé ne
pas avoir aucun rapport avec la Chine
monsieur le rapporteur il me semble que
vous évoquez des faits qui se sont
passés en Chine et qui correspondent
l'activité à l'activité de filiales et
même de sous filiales du groupe bidens
en Chine il me semble que
les préoccupations encore une fois
légitimes de votre commission porte sur
Tik Tok et sur l'activité de Tik Tok en
France
d'un point de vue droit des sociétés il
me semble avoir démontré que bidens
étant immatriculé effectivement
oser le caïman et étant actionnaires à
100% de Tik Tok limité de lui-même
immatriculé dans les îles Caïmans avec
une chaîne qui redescend jusqu'à Tic-Toc
SAS en France fait que d'un point de vue
juridique il n'y a absolument aucune
possibilité d'avoir des pressions ou des
demandes des interventions de la part du
gouvernement chinois ou de tout entité
chinoise il n'y a aucun pourcentage du
capital de bidens ou de Tik Tok qui soit
détenu par une entité émanant de la
Chine
d'autre part nous publions dans un
rapport de transparence qui est
trimestriel l'ensemble des demandes des
autorités administratives de tous les
pays du monde qui sont effectuées auprès
de Tik Tok voilà donc dès qu'un
gouvernement s'adresse à Tik Tok demande
communication d'information
dans le cadre de procédure
administrative et judiciaire nous les
publions donc c'est comme ça que nous
savons qu'il a eu 228 demandes
effectuées par la France au premier
semestre 2022 qu'il y en a eu 1150 en
Allemagne il y en a 0 qui émane de la
Chine et pour une raison simple c'est
que nous n'opérons pas en Chine que Tik
Tok ne perd pas en Chine donc il y a
cette étanchéité qui est bien assurée à
la fois dans le droit des sociétés et
qui est assuré aussi par des outils de
transparence et je ne reviens pas
évidemment sur tout le dispositif
technique que nous avons évoqué donc la
Constitution la création avec ses
datacenter protégées avec cette tiers
partie avec ces systèmes de lutte contre
les cyber-intrusions et faites aussi
pour répondre à vos attentes légitimes
pour faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait aucune
possibilité de partir atteinte à
l'intégrité de Tik Tok même si un
dirigeant de Tik Tok ou de by dance le
demander et c'est d'ailleurs c'est comme
je disais c'est un Irlandais basé en
Irlande qui dirige l'entité trust sensei
donc même dans ce cas où il y aurait une
demande adressée à une importante
personnalité travailler dans le groupe
ce système de sécurité avec ses droits
d'accès permet que ce soit impossible
alors vous nous dites depuis le début de
cette audition vous nous l'avez répété
plusieurs fois Tik Tok n'est pas
disponible en Chine continentale tandis
que douille n'est pas disponible en
dehors de la Chine continentale donc il
n'y a aucun rapport
mais vous ne nous dites pas pourquoi Tik
Tok ne perd pas en Chine continentale
Tik Tok ne perd pas en Chine parce qu'il
est interdit en Chine continentale comme
les gafam comme Facebook comme
Twitter et comme Google etc etc par le
gouvernement
pourquoi
ne protestez-vous pas comme les autres
comme les gafam
contre cette interdiction d'un
gouvernement totalitaire cette censure
qui empêche les plateformes qui ne sont
pas chinoises d'intervenir en Chine
si vous êtes totalement indépendant ça
devrait pas vous poser de problème mais
je pense que vous devriez pouvoir
protester comme le fond Facebook Google
etc ça sert à rien mais au moins on
proteste et on montre où est le bon
droit alors sur ce sur ce terrain là
comme vous l'avez peut-être constaté
lorsque vous ouvrez l'application Tik
Tok qui est une application
communautaire c'est à dire que Tik Tok
ne produit pas de contenu c'est ce sont
les utilisateurs qui créent des contenus
vous pouvez voir que si vous allez sur
des hashtags enfin dans des Maud dièses
oui gourd par exemple ce modèle a été
visionné plus de 400 millions de fois
c'est à dire que vous avez des vidéos
qui défendent ces communautés qui sont
tout à fait en accès libre et partagé
sur l'application Tik Tok donc la
liberté d'expression est totale y
compris pour critiquer tel ou tel
gouvernement sauf en Chine Tic-Toc est
présent dans un très grand nombre de
pays et elle est utilisée par des
communautés y compris les communautés
wiggorge je sais que vous êtes très
attachés à ce sujet et qui peuvent
s'exprimer librement sur Tik Tok pour
défendre leurs droits et parler de leur
communauté de même que vous avez je
crois auditionné Raphaël Glucksmann il y
a pas très longtemps qui lui raconte
aussi sur Tik Tok sur lequel il fait
état de tous ces discours très critiques
sur le gouvernement chinois et il fait
d'ailleurs des très beaux scores
d'audience donc le rôle le rôle de Tik
Tok si vous me permettez c'est d'être
justement cet espace de liberté
d'expression totale dans le respect
évidemment de la tolérance d'autrui mais
où chacun peut exprimer ses idées sans
aucune forme de censure
vous êtes directeur des affaires
publiques d'une société
dans la maison mère
qui publie 400 millions de messages ou
de vidéos je ne sais pas sur les ouigo
Chinois
et les seuls qui ne peuvent pas voir
cela
ce sont les Chinois et vous avez dans le
même groupe by dance Caiman la société
l'entreprise douille qui est chinoise et
qui bien évidemment est totalement
censuré il n'y a pas seulement les wigos
il y a la guerre en Ukraine etc
est-ce que vous trouvez normal
d'appartenir à un groupe
ou la société qui dit toute la vérité
qui dit en tout cas tout ce que tout le
monde a le droit de dire et qui parle
librement n'est pas accessible en Chine
et que dans ce même groupe il y a une
société qui est pratiquement la même
avec un algorithme qui a été développé
au départ pratiquement identique et qui
restait très largement identique et qui
est totalement censuré par le
gouvernement chinois
[Musique]
ça vous ne protestez pas
moi je suis fier en tout cas
d'appartenir à une entreprise à une
plateforme qui s'appelle Tik Tok et qui
promeut le dialogue des cultures de
toutes les cultures ou la liberté
d'expression est totale j'aurais été
évidemment très mal à l'aise dans le cas
contraire sans doute que je ne serai pas
là mais justement pour précisément Tik
Tok et cette plateforme qui permet
d'opérer alors en respectant les lois en
vigueur dans chaque pays donc il y a
d'autres pays que la Chine ou parfois ça
peut poser problème mais à chaque fois
nous avons défendu la liberté
d'expression nous avons d'ailleurs
publié un engagement en faveur des
droits de l'homme Tik Tok a publié cet
engagement enfin avoir des droits de
l'homme
qui est donc dans la mesure du possible
à chaque fois qu'il y a une difficulté
nous
maintenant et nous défendons la liberté
d'expression et on peut parler de tout
sujet sur Tik Tok y compris de la de la
Chine
à titre personnel que ce que vous pensez
de la politique du gouvernement chinois
envers les Ouigours
mais si vous m'interrogez à titre
personnel bien entendu que je suis je
condamne toutes les atteintes qui peut y
avoir dans au droit de l'homme et pas
seulement Chine dans le monde entier
et on verra les Tibétains
les Tibétains et comme je vous le disais
dans bien d'autres pays il hélas des
attentes au droit de l'homme et
précisément Tik Tok et cette plateforme
où toutes les ONG peuvent s'exprimer en
toute liberté
on a même je dis ça parce que c'est que
c'était quelque chose d'important pour
vous les décomptes de Médecins sans
frontières qui font des très belles
vidéos comme la Croix-Rouge et qui
permettent justement d'être les voix de
ces de ces libertés et de ces peuples
qui justement aspirent la liberté
et quel est votre réunion personnelle
sur la censure massive exercée par le
gouvernement chinois sur les contenus de
nos sociétés de votre groupe qui
s'appelle douillet il me semble que je
viens avant tout de votre commission
pour parler comme directeur des
relations institutionnelles de Tik Tok
en France pour ce qu'ils concerne la
France oui mais si vous me parlez à
titre personnel oui bien sûr que je
considère que il faut défendre la
liberté partout dans le monde et c'est
justement l'intérêt de cette plateforme
qui s'appelle Tik Tok c'est de permettre
ce dialogue des cultures cette meilleure
compréhension qui est si nécessaire
aujourd'hui au moment où les tensions
grandissent entre les entre les peuples
et les continents
merci est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
quelle est la part de Tik Tok France
dans les bénéfices de Tik Tok caïman
alors
si vous me permettez sur ces tous ces
sujets comme Tik Tok et n'est pas une
entreprise côté et
nous sommes préférable de pouvoir
échanger par écrit en tout cas dans un
cadre confidentiel sur les données qui
sont les données effectivement
économiques ou fiscales
si vous me le permettez
bien j'en ai terminé avec la première
partie peut-être que si comme ça semble
devoir durer peut-être on pourrait
passer et puis ensuite
je vous propose qu'on tourne et si on
est sur des sujets qui sont recreusés
après on essaiera de de recadrer tout ça
avant de passer la parole à l'ancienne
j'aurais une ou deux questions courtes
je suis pas spécialiste de comment dire
du positionnement politique des
îles Caïmans en faveur du développement
du numérique donc je mesure mal la
raison de
la domiciliation îles Caïmans mais pour
ce qui est de
l'entité en Irlande pourquoi l'Irlande
on aurait été ravi en France d'avoir les
40 000 personnes
ça je n'ai pas de commentaires
particuliers à faire si sinon que
l'Irlande c'est vrai j'ai choisi pour
par un grand nombre d'entreprises de
technologie pour pour s'installer voilà
mais en tout cas
je pense que c'est intéressant de savoir
qu'il y a aussi un bureau en France avec
plus de 200 salariés aujourd'hui qui a
grandi très vite puisque quand j'étais
recruté il y avait au moment de mes
entretiens de recrutement on était
quatre puis 20 et là on est plus de 200
donc je pense qu'il y a quand même un
intérêt fort à développer une présence
en France
voilà parce que
peut-être qu'il y a une question aussi
de fiscalité sans faire de procès
d'intention n'est pas là pour faire les
procès mais peut-être une question de
fiscalité et de degré d'exigence de la
CNIL entre guillemets irlandaise mais
ça chacun pourra pourra se faire son
idée pour ne pas revenir dessus par
rapport à la présentation initiale que
vous avez tenu à faire sur votre rôle au
sein de Tik Tok SS est-ce que je peux
vous demander puisque vous êtes haut
fonctionnaire et que cette importance
pour nous de comprendre comment sont
utilisés les compétences et les
ressources de la fonction publique
française
à quel moment avez-vous eu votre premier
contact avec by dance
monsieur le Président donc je suis
fonctionnaire évidemment en
disponibilité c'est-à-dire je veux bien
compris
ça devait être en mars 2020 je pense
mars avril 2020 je pense dans vos
fonctions antérieures vous n'avez pas eu
l'occasion de traiter avec
d'accord c'est clair
vos fonctions aujourd'hui en tant que
directeur des affaires publiques
êtes-vous salarié de Tik Tok SS où
êtes-vous prestataire de Tik Tok les 16
dans la mesure où dans la présentation
nous avons fait et qui avait l'air de
vous convenir vous êtes également le le
patron d'une d'une entreprise de
à l'enseigne non alors je suis salarié
effectivement je suis salarié à plein
temps de Tik Tok SAS d'accord et votre
votre entreprise de conseil n'est pas
prestataire non non pas absolument pas
non encore et vous n'êtes pas
prestataire non plus pour d'autres
entités Tik Tok dans d'autres pays
européens absolument pas non non non
vraiment j'exerce ma totalité de mon
activité pour Tik Tok très bien je vous
remercie madame Rossignol ensuite
j'avais madame Morin de Saïd qui avait
vu la main monsieur gatolin monsieur
Cardon et après on repassera monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
j'ai quatre questions j'ai fait une par
une où j'ai des groupes
comme vous voulez président
ma première monsieur d'abord je connais
les règles de Tik Tok concernant la
lutte contre la pornographie les nude
etc je crois savoir que votre vos outils
pour tenir vos engagements sont
essentiellement des algorithmes et non
pas et en plus grande proportion des
algorithmes que des ressources humaines
la preuve en est qu'il vous arrive de
passer complètement à côté d'un certain
nombre de diffusion vous avez vu une
affaire comme ça il y a quelques mois
avec les Dick pics qui sont propagés sur
Tik Tok pendant plusieurs jours et
malgré des signalements et qui ont
adminément révélé que certaines choses
pouvaient échapper à vos algorithmes et
vous je sais que vous avez aussi signé
la Charte européenne contre le
développement de la haine en ligne ma
première question est est-ce que vous
avez l'intention de recruter des moyens
humains qui sont plus efficaces et dans
quelle proportion ou est-ce que vous
continuez de faire confiance aux
algorithmes pour lutter contre la haine
en ligne ou encore d'autres
attractions d'autres formes
d'attractivité qui vous sont reprochés
qui concernent l'apologie de la maigreur
les mutilations etc qui circulent
puisque comme vous le dites il n'y a pas
de vidéo Tik Tok il n'y a que des vidéos
que les gens mettent sur TikTok ça c'est
ma première question concerne la source
humaine la dernière question est lié à
celle là
quels sont les moyens que vous entendez
mettre en place ou que vous mettez déjà
en place et avec quels résultats pour
lutter contre le grooming
pédopornographique
tout le monde sait ce que c'est que le
Browning pédo-bornographique consiste
qui consiste à utiliser les réseaux
sociaux pour entrer en contact avec des
mineurs et les attirer sur d'autres
sites et qui est un des sujets après mes
deux autres questions sont un peu moins
techniques peut-être
vous avez été au service de l'État
vous avez été Président du CNC c'est ça
j'ai bien entendu je j'imagine donc à ce
moment là dans votre parcours vous aviez
une certaine idée de ce que de ce que
sont les politiques culturelles de leurs
fonctions et une certaine idée de
l'accès à la culture est-ce que vous
considérez qu'aujourd'hui en tant que
chargé des affaires publiques de Tik Tok
votre activité est cohérente avec ce que
vous avez pu promouvoir un moment donné
en gros est-ce que le fait d'être dans
les affaires publiques d'une société
dont tout le monde connaît la toxicité
par la méthode des algorithmes
ces algorithmes qui contribuent à
enfermer des jeunes dans une
consommation
d'un volume de vidéo que aucune autre
plateforme n'atteint dans les mêmes à
même rapidité qui consiste à les
enfermés ou les conduire dans des sujets
qui sont supposés être leur sujet
d'intérêt est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est comme ça que vous contribuez à
former des citoyens ou est-ce que vous
avez renoncé à former des citoyens et ma
dernière question vous venez de nous
dire que vous êtes en disponibilité de
la haute fonction publique
pourquoi vous ne démissionnez pas est-ce
que vous pensez que les fonctions que
vous
occupez actuellement sont compatibles
avec un retour un jour dans la fonction
publique et au service de l'État
merci madame la sénatrice donc quatre
questions importantes alors la première
sur les ressources humaines ce qui est
important c'est de combiner au mieux
compte tenu de des flux parce que c'est
il y a évidemment une très grande
quantité de vidéo qui sont postées
chaque jour en France et dans le monde
entier donc la toute la question est de
combiner au mieux l'intelligence
artificielle ce qu'on appelle le machine
learning c'est à dire des algorithmes
qui effectivement vont apprendre de
mieux en mieux à détecter des images qui
peuvent être des images pornographiques
au pied de pornographiques pour
reprendre vos centres d'intérêt ou des
images de nudité de des mots d'insultes
tout ce qui est en ligne extrémisme
nazisme racisme etc donc c'est ces
algorithmes vont quand même déjà faire
une grosse partie du travail et c'est ce
qui fait d'ailleurs que
97% des contenus qui sont retirés sur
Tik Tok le son de manière proactive
c'est à dire
sans aucun signalement c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle 88% de ces contenus
sont retirés avant 24 heures
et donc c'est cette démarche évidemment
ce perfectionne avec des ressources
d'intelligence artificielle récemment un
lanceur d'alerte signalait que c'est
effectivement la manière dont sont
conçus ces algorithmes c'est
que qui permet de s'assurer que ces
contenus seront retirés très rapidement
et qui ne reviendront pas sur la
plateforme et ensuite vous avez raison
il y a aussi le travail humain quand
vous avez une vidéo avec une croix
gammée ça peut être une vidéo néonazi ça
peut être une vidéo du Mémorial de la
Shoah que nous sommes très heureux
d'avoir accueilli sur la plateforme pour
faire de la pédagogie sur la Shoah et la
lutte contre le néonazisme donc c'est
pour ça que nous avons des modérateurs
humains et quand je citais 40000
personnes c'est ça fait la taille de je
crois peut-être je sais pas la ville
d'Angoulême quelque chose comme ça c'est
c'est c'est massif ce sont des effectifs
très nombreux 40 000 personnes et en
avant donc je disais à peu près 600 en
langue française et qui vont me faire
que
regarder des contenus en langue
française et faire des interprétations
plus fines des choses là où il y a
parfois des ou c'est le sujet est un peu
plus difficile c'est le harcèlement
parce que le harcèlement est un sujet
sur lequel on a besoin d'avoir un
contexte et on a des vidéos qui peuvent
être anodines et qu'en réalité sont des
vidéos de harcèlement il faut connaître
le contexte c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons des signal à l'heure
de confiance il enfance stop fisha point
de contact ce sont des organisations qui
sont spécialisées dans la détection de
ces contenus on est même en train de
d'insérer le 30 18 qui est le numéro de
i en France puisqu'on sait que parfois
les jeunes ils préfèrent chatter ils
préfèrent échanger
textuellement pour parler de leurs
problèmes voilà on est en train
d'intégrer ça dans Tik Tok pour pouvoir
aussi faire de la détection j'allais
dire anticiper la prévention c'est
extrêmement important donc on a une
chaîne de signalement avec des de
confiance qui permet d'être encore plus
rapide
sur la lutte contre la pédopornographie
donc vous le rappeliez nous sommes
membres d'un grand nombre d'associations
de coalition on est membre par exemple
de 8 protect qui est la plus grande
alliance multisectorielle pour lutter
contre
l'exploitation sexuelle des enfants en
ligne
ce qui est très important de noter là
aussi pour la prévention c'est que quand
vous avez des jeunes et notamment des
très jeunes c'est à dire de 13 à 18 ans
des mineurs quand ils ont entre 13 et 15
ans
et bien ils n'ont pas de messagerie par
exemple pas de messagerie pas de
possibilité d'envoyer des messages leur
compte est privé par défaut
ils peuvent pas télécharger de vidéos
ils peuvent pas profiter de certaines
fonctionnalités comme les duos les
stitchs etc
et évidemment on encourage très
fortement
à l'acouplage avec le fait le Family
Perrine donc le contrôle parental
l'assistance aux familles qui permet
ensuite y compris de déterminer le temps
d'écran on sait que c'est un sujet aussi
de
préoccupation donc d'ailleurs maintenant
depuis quelques mois le temps d'écran
est limité à 60 minutes par défaut vous
verrez peut-être en revenir dessus voilà
donc on veille aussi à ce que des
fonctionnalités soient restreintes et
même entre 16 et 18 ans la messagerie
sera aussi désactivée par défaut on sait
que c'est par la messagerie que parfois
les connexions se font et d'ailleurs
même si la messagerie est activée le
jeune ne pourra pas envoyer de pièces
jointes on peut pas envoyer de pièces
jointes sur Tik Tok donc ça aussi ça
évite le chantage au nude etc voilà donc
ça ça fait partie des éléments de
réponse sur l'accès à la culture je
il est presque en introduction c'est à
dire ça m'a intéressé de venir chez Tik
Tok parce qu'effectivement je suis
passionné de culture et je suis
passionné de transmission culturelle et
je retrouve à la fois chez Tik Tok
une nouvelle génération de créateurs
qui justement utilise ces outils très
nouveau très perfectionnés même des
filtres des effets en été augmentés et
donc on a des vrais cinéastes qui
émergent sur la plateforme Tik Tok c'est
pas pour rien d'ailleurs qu'on a fait
une compétition internationale de de
film Tik Tok le format vertical conduit
à une nouvelle écriture donc c'est
intéressant d'un point de vue artistique
on sait souvent le médium et le médium
et le message
et vous parlez de toxicité
nous avons engagé des travaux importants
pour que les algorithmes soient source
de découverte
évidemment on enferme jamais les gens
dans des bulles ce qui serait ce qui
serait très très mauvais
et donc l'algorithme vise au contraire à
stimuler l'utilisateur lui proposant des
choses qui ne sont pas forcément dans
ces préférences exprimées ou dans son
historique de parcours sur l'application
donc il y a une fonction de test de
voilà de contenu nouveau si vous avez
aimé je sais pas la gastronomie coréenne
peut-être que vous irez les séries
coréennes parfois ce sont même des
associations qui sont encore moins
évidentes mais l'algorithme avec les
informations qu'il a pu générer
test en tout cas des nouvelles des
nouveaux contenus pour voir si vous
allez adhérer à ces contenus on veille à
ce que vous n'ayez jamais dans le fil
pour toi deux vidéos du même créateur ou
deux vidéos du même son on veille aussi
est-ce que les contenus qui sont
autorisés mais qui dont la consommation
excessive des mêmes contenus peut
entraîner justement des problèmes si
vous regardez que des vidéos avec des
régimes amincissants c'est pas bon si
vous regardez que des vidéos de fitness
c'est pas bon non plus donc ce type de
produit enfin de pardon de contenu on
veille aussi à ce qui ne soit pas fourni
en trop grande quantité dans un même
flux pour que justement les gens qui ont
tendance à aller vers des pratiques un
peu extrêmes ne soient pas encouragés à
le faire et voir même parfois on leur
propose des ressources on leur dit mais
voilà vous avez tapé ce mot ce mot
suicide par exemple évidemment non
seulement montre pas de vidéo de suicide
mais en plus on va vous emmener vers
une page qui va vous aider à prendre
soin de vous et éventuellement à donner
l'alerte vous dites on fait ça ce que
vous avez des tiers qui peuvent évaluer
ça et publier des rapports ou des
évaluations de ça alors ça me permet
monsieur le Président de d'évoquer
quelque chose qui est important c'est
que et on reviendra la dernière question
c'était que effectivement nous avons
donc c'est ces partenariats alors avec
la protection d'enfant je citer et en
France point de contact respecte zone
pour la lutte contre les informations ou
les inspiration au travail avec
génération numérique conspiration
et d'autres donc effectivement on a tout
un panel de ONG d'associations qu'on
associe à nos travaux on a même un
conseil consultatif européen est-ce
qu'il y a des gens qui publient des
rapports où est-ce que vous envisagez
que des gens publient des rapports
régulièrement pour venir vérifier par
exemple moi si je dis comme mère que mes
jeux dans le parc sont tout à fait
sécurisés évidemment on va me croire sur
ma bonne tête mais c'est mieux quand
j'ai Sécuritas qui qui passe voyez vous
avez tout à fait raison c'est cette
logique d'air de tiers de confiance
qu'on utilise aussi pour la sécurisation
des données des centres de données et
effectivement on souhaite le faire aussi
pour pouvoir auditer nos algorithmes de
recommandation nous algorithmes de
modération ou même se confirmateur
commercial la librairie de vidéos
commerciales et donc le DSA d'ailleurs
nous oblige à le faire et c'est très
bien puisque on avait déjà qui le fait
voilà donc en fait ce sont des API nous
créons des API en ce moment il y en a
une qui est déjà développée aux
États-Unis ces API en fait c'est ce qui
permet à des chercheurs université des
effectivement des experts extérieurs de
pouvoir interroger les algorithmes
pouvoir tester la plateforme est-ce
qu'il y a des tunnels est-ce que on
enferme les gens dans des bus etc vous
avez des rapports de ce type là alors
c'est à dire que nous sommes en train de
déployer ces outils alors oui il y a un
rapport par exemple aux États-Unis parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a commencé aux
États-Unis la pays a déjà été créé et
par exemple la Georgian tech University
donc université de l'État de Géorgie
a publié un rapport on sera preneur du
rapport voilà on vous l'enverra en fait
c'est un rapport intéressant parce que
c'est un rapport qui établit qu'il n'y a
pas de censure ou de propagande de de la
Chine notamment parce que c'était le
sujet mais même d'autres pays sur sur
Tik Tok donc c'est un rapport important
et cet université est totalement
indépendante et travaille même pour le
Pentagone donc on vous enverra le
rapport bien entendu sur la dernière
question de même Rossignol et ensuite
alors la déontologie bien entendu à
chaque fois que j'ai
quand j'ai quitté le service public
pour créer ma société puis pour
rejoindre Tik Tok j'ai demandé bien
entendu
de la commission déontologie donc j'ai
deux avis positifs de la commission
d'anthologique d'ailleurs je peux vous
remettre si vous le souhaitez et quand
j'ai rejoint Tik Tok j'ai même demandé
d'ailleurs mon déontologue de
l'instruction des finances m'a conseillé
de saisir la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique que j'ai
saisi et qui a estimé que j'ai en fait
je n'avais pas à la saisir dans ce cas
de figure voilà mais donc j'ai fait
toutes les démarches pour m'assurer de
cette déontologie que je ne prenais pas
de risque et je faisais pas prendre de
risques à mon administration et la
question de savoir pourquoi j'ai pas
démissionné d'une part parce que la
règle en fait c'est que on se met en
disponibilité et puis au bout d'un
certain temps on est démissionné de fait
voilà donc c'est ce qui applique
l'ensemble de mes collègues à ma
connaissance alors pourquoi pas
démissionner alors c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois que que l'administration m'a
demandé de m'intéresser à un problème
public c'est vrai que j'ai tendance
spontanément à essayer de dire oui parce
que je suis un passionné de la cause
publique
voilà donc je n'ai pas d'autres d'autres
choses à dire il me semble que c'est une
façon aussi de servir son pays que de
travailler dans une entreprise
particulièrement innovante
particulièrement disruptive et que ce
savoir que j'accumule peut être utile à
mon pays et je pense d'ailleurs que tous
les salariés de Tik Tok SAS en France
ils sont ils sont très jeunes pour la
plupart ils se disent voilà je travaille
pour une entreprise qui est en France je
travaille aussi pour mon pays et j'aide
des entités des musées des le Pôle
emploi par exemple j'aide les armées à
recruter des jeunes
sur vous OK
merci monsieur le Président il y a bien
anciens haut fonctionnaires qui ont
rejoint quantité d'entreprises
extra-européennes du domaine de du
numérique c'est un vaste sujet chers
collègues Charleroi
sans doute un peu plus tard j'ai deux
questions si vous me le permettez
monsieur le Président la première est
dans le prolongement des questions de
Madame Rossignol concernant les
algorithmes qui sont notre grande
préoccupation parce que ces algorithmes
sont conçus pour enfermer pour capter
l'attention et bien sûr
c'est une proclamation notamment
vis-à-vis de de nos jeunes à des âges
critiques ou on est dans des phases
d'apprentissage et de découverte du
monde
vous savez que d'ici quelques semaines
maintenant d'ici trois mois le DSA
s'appliquera
pour ma part ayant été rapportés ce
projet de règlement pour notre
commission des affaires européennes je
pense que nous ne sommes pas allés assez
loin notamment concernant le contrôle et
l'évaluation des des algorithmes
est-ce que dans le cadre de
l'application du DSA et peut-être pour
aller plus loin pour rassurer justement
les utilisateurs la plateforme TikTok
est prête à se laisser auditer par des
chercheurs indépendants tout type
confondus et prête aussi peut-être à
rapprocher ces dates d'évaluation pour
ma part je trouve que c'était trop trop
espacés
est-ce que également vous comptez
recruter un peu plus de monde parce que
la modération la veille c'est le sujet
le plus important en réalité pour être
compatible avec l'exécution de ce
règlement
est-ce que vous opposerez forcément le
secret des affaires justement à ces
otites ces audits des des algorithmes
qui sont au cœur de de la problématique
voilà une première série de questions je
voulais vous poser je dis ça aussi parce
que il y a quelques jours
un géant des représentant des big tech
Elon Musk pour pas le citer qui s'est
retiré d'ailleurs du code des bonnes
pratiques en ligne laisser entendre que
voilà Twitter n'appliquerait pas
forcément l'application du du DSA il
était en cela d'ailleurs repris par le
commissaire européen terrible breton Tik
Tok clairement s'engage t'es vraiment
entre pleinement dans l'application du
dessin
avant que vous ne répondiez c'est pour
la bonne organisation des débats dans la
mesure où il y a une partie également
sur les sur les algorithmes bien
évidemment
je propose que nous notions les
questions d'amour de saillie pour faire
un paquet global pour pas qu'on se
disperse si vous en êtes d'accord
oui la seule chose c'est que
voilà pouvez-vous répondre alors
succinctement sur la sur la question du
DSA de son application de ce que vous
comptez faire et enfin succinctement non
répondez mais simplement on en reparlera
après sur les doses d'aspects
l'algorithmes parce que je veux dire
bien sûr merci monsieur le Président et
merci Madame merci sénatrice
j'attends la réponse à la première
question si vous voulez
la question est fondamentale donc merci
de la poser bien entendu nous
appliquerons le DSA nous serons au
rendez-vous en août prochain et nous
sommes déjà au rendez-vous en réalité
sur un certain nombre de dispositifs
nous avons eu le plaisir d'accueillir la
com à Dublin à notre centre de
transparence
puisque nous avons deux centres de
transparence nous en avons un aux
États-Unis depuis 2020 et nous avons un
centre de transparence à Dublin et
l'arcom a pu échanger avec des cadres de
très haut niveau de l'entité trust and
safety et de l'entité juridique et nous
avons justement voulu avoir cette
échange sur le sur le DSA et donc la
réponse est oui nous voulons être le
plus transparent possible sur les
algorithmes de recommandation de
modération nous développons les API qui
sont demandés par le DSA et nous sommes
très heureux qu'elle puisse être bientôt
ouverte nous avons travaillé avec le
média laps de Sciences Po par exemple en
bêta test sur l'API qui concernait les
bibliothèques de vidéos commerciales et
cette opération s'est très bien passée
de part et d'autre et donc oui nous
sommes aussi avec le vigime sur les les
ingérences sur les risques d'ingérence
nous travaillons avec le pérenne à Bercy
au ministère des Finances et nous sommes
ouverts à travailler avec des
universitaires il faut juste évidemment
que ce soit fait correctement dans des
bonnes conditions de sécurité puisqu'on
sait que parfois c'est aussi des
ouvertures à considérer de qui ont qui
ont aussi suscité des problèmes parce
qu'après vous pouvez pouvoir des
personnes malveillantes aussi qui
essaient d'utiliser cette information
donc dès lors que c'est bien fait dans
des conditions de sécurité qui sont
d'ailleurs prévues par le DSA nous
voulons faire un exercice de
transparence maximale en direction des
chercheurs et des autorités de
régulation je ne veux pas anticiper
peut-être une question du rapporteur
mais vous avez parlé des agences
étrangères pouvez-vous ici affirmer que
par exemple la différence d'une
plateforme comme facebook qui dans
l'affaire comme j'ai Activia a démontrer
qu'elle a disposé de failles de backdows
pour utiliser un anglicisme pouvez-vous
garantir que Tik Tok ne dispose d'aucune
faille
alors ce que ce que ce que l'on publie
régulièrement maintenant dans y compris
dans notre rapport de transparence ce
sont les tentatives
d'intrusion d'ingérence les
comportements authentiques
inauthentiques coordonnées donc dès que
nous détectons ce genre de choses ça
peut arriver
dans ce cas là évidemment nous interrons
tout de suite pour retirer ses comptes
et nous publions nous publions les
résultats en France par exemple tout
s'est bien passé lors des dernières
élections donc non seulement on a fait
un très bon travail d'information mais
on n'a pas repéré de tentatives
d'ingérence dans les élections
françaises
au Kenya on a on a remarqué que il y
avait eu ces tentatives et qui ont été
déjoués et donc on veille à chaque fois
d'une part à mettre en place des équipes
de veille renforcer lorsqu'il y a des
élections et d'autre part à communiquer
sur les résultats de cette action de
veille que nous avons et qui est qui est
très forte
ma dernière question c'est porte sur les
données la sécurisation de nos données
vous avez parlé de Data Center qui était
en construction donc en Europe mais il
n'y a pas que la question de
l'hébergement des données il y a la
question de leur traitement et surtout
il y a la question des lois extra
territoriales qui font que on est bien
démunis face justement à cette
sécurisation
de nos données vous avez dit que vous
disposez des meilleurs outils
technologiques pour empêcher ces données
de nous échapper comment pouvez-vous
l'affirmer parce que dans dans la
réalité on sait bien que les données
sont tout à fait capables par ces pays
étrangers
merci pour pour cette question donc
nous nous plaçons toujours dans la le
pire des cas où effectivement un
individu essaie de pénétrer le système
donc c'est d'ailleurs toutes les
entreprises essaient de Paris ce risque
donc la façon dont nous avons et on nous
travaillons à éviter ce risque c'est
effectivement de localiser les centres
des données au plus près des des pays
dans lesquels on opère et c'est pour ça
qu'on développe ces trois Data Center à
Dublin et en Norvège ensuite on utilise
à la fois nos protections internes et un
tiers de confiance européen pour aussi
rassurer y compris vous rassurer aussi
sur le fait que on ne repose pas que sur
eux-mêmes comme disait monsieur
rapporteur monsieur le Président avec un
Veritas voilà nous on travaille aussi
avec des tiers de confiance qui vont
effectuer ces tests et qui vont assurer
cette cette sécurisation ensuite on
diminue au maximum
les besoins de d'accès aux données ou
les transferts de données au maximum
c'est à dire on est une plateforme de
communication internationale on n'est
pas une banque on n'est pas un
coffre-fort donc comme on a une
plateforme de communication il est
normal que les vidéos circulent moi
quand je veux quand vous faites une
vidéo vous voulez qu'elle soit vue par
un maximum de personnes mais si par
exemple j'ai une vidéo que je mets en
mode public et finalement je change
d'avis je veux la remettre en mode privé
il faut bien que l'information puisse
circuler pour que cette vidéo soit
ensuite rebasculée en mode privé donc la
donnée il y a bien une donnée qui va
circuler donc on peut pas on peut pas
dire il y aura pas de circulation de
données de la façon qu'on a des Data
analystes qui doivent pouvoir analyser
aussi
quelle est l'efficacité d'un filtre par
exemple une fonctionnalité mais dans ce
cas-là ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
agréger les données on va les anonymiser
on va faire en sorte que ne soit pas
rattaché à des à des comptes
particuliers donc réduction du volume
d'échange de données ou réduction des
nombres d'accès aux données notamment
les données personnelles et après c'est
même réduction du nombre de personnes
qui peuvent avoir accès à ces données
sur ces trois sur ces trois piliers qui
nous permettent selon nous d'assurer le
meilleur niveau de sécurité possible et
peut-être de contribuer à définir un
nouveau standard de sécurité et
finalement une application de ce
principe de souveraineté numérique qui
vous est cher notamment de souveraineté
européenne
je suppose que monsieur le rapporteur
puisse justement
mettre les choses en perspective sur les
données
et on reprendra les questions derrière
sur le sujet bien sûr monsieur cardan
monsieur gatelin et j'ai eu madame
Bourrat aussi
[Musique]
alors en ce qui concerne les transferts
de données jusqu'en juin 2022 TikTok
répétait sans cesse empêcher tout
transfert ou consultation des données
des utilisateurs vers la Chine par la
Chine
jusqu'à ce que BuzzFeed révèle le
contenu de 80 enregistrements audio
issus de réunions internes à
l'entreprise
on s'est aperçu que des ingénieurs de
l'application de partage de vidéo ont eu
accès depuis la Chine à pas mal
d'informations
les enregistrements de bus 8 prouvaient
l'existence d'un administrateur
principal je cite en Chine qui avait
accès à tout
je cite encore tout est vu en Chine à
faire un membre du trust snifty
département
des enregistrements de huit salariés
américains montrent qu'ils ont dû se
tourner vers leur collecte chinois pour
savoir comment circuler les données de
leurs concitoyens ils n'avaient pas la
permission d'y accéder eux-mêmes
évidemment comme d'habitude TikTok
confronté à des preuves a fini par
reconnaître la vérité
d'ailleurs en 2021 Tik Tok avait déjà dû
payer 92 millions de dollars à la
justice américaine en raison de fuite
vers la Chine de donner personnelle
d'utilisateurs donc le rapport de Bussy
il date pas d'y a 10 ans il date d'il y
a un an
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui
monsieur rapporteur la situation est
celle que je viens de décrire c'est à
dire que mais je peux aller un peu plus
dans les détails c'est à dire que à la
fois la construction de du projet Texas
aux États-Unis et la
création des dettes à Center et de
dispositifs de protection qui sont mis
en oeuvre en Europe sont destinés à
éviter toute tout transfert de données
non autorisées tout accès à nos autorisé
avec la certification d'une entité
tierce et d'une entité européenne dans
le cas du projet Clover dans le cas du
projet américain on est allé encore plus
loin puisque c'est même Oracle le Cloud
d'ORAC qui gère et cette opérationnel
qui gère les données des utilisateurs
américains dans une entité une enclave
sécurisée qui s'appelle usds avec 1000
employés qui travaillent
l'investissement d'un milliard 500
millions de dollars aux États-Unis et en
Europe nous sommes en train nous avons
engagé un investissement d'un milliard
200 millions d'euros qui sont qui sera
une des points à un investissement
annuel pour assurer cette la mise en
oeuvre de ce de ce dispositif donc c'est
de cette manière que nous pouvons éviter
tout risque d'intrusion d'accès non
autorisés
alors c'est un des problèmes avec Tik
Tok comme d'ailleurs c'est pas
spécificatif comme avec toutes les
plateformes c'est à dire qu'on prend
toujours des engagements
et qu'on tarde beaucoup beaucoup aller
voir venir le projet Texas ça fait 4 ans
ça fait 2019 qu'il a été annoncé qu'il
est travaillé qu'on annonce Oracle etc
ça fait 4 ans et en 2019 pendant quand
il a été annoncé Tik Tok avait quelques
années seulement il a pas eu de problème
pour se développer à toute vitesse
donc jusqu'où ce qui va falloir attendre
que les choses se mettent en place
jusqu'où pendant combien de temps est-ce
qu'on va prendre des engagements sur les
transferts de données sur ceci cela de
la même façon le projet Clover vous avez
annoncé déjà il y a au moins un an ou
deux en Europe vous n'avez pas voulu
révéler jusqu'à présent les le nom des
sociétés avec laquelle vous avec
lesquels vous comptez travailler ce qui
est pas vraiment une preuve de
transparence évidente est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous dire aujourd'hui et
surtout est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner une une date à quel le projet
Texas sera définitivement mis en place
et une date à laquelle le projet Clover
sera définitivement mis en place parce
que ça peut encore durer 5 ans avec des
engagements permanents auprès de la
Commission européenne auprès de l'arcom
auprès des régulateurs c'est un vrai
problème le fait que qu'on ne puisse pas
obtenir des plateformes autre chose que
des engagements qui ne sont pas tenus
par ailleurs j'ajoute juste une question
puisque qui reprend ce que vous venez de
dire vous nous avez dit que tout
transfert de données non autorisée sera
à partir de ces projets impossible moi
ce que je souhaiterais ce n'est pas que
tout transfert de données non autorisées
soit impossible c'est que tout transfert
de données soit impossible à ce
moment-là on pourra dire que vous êtes
indépendant de la Chine mais pour le
moment vous nous dites tout transfert de
données non autorisées c'est-à-dire que
vous comptez autoriser des données
encore vers différents pays et notamment
vers la Chine alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire lorsque ce sera terminé
il n'y aura plus de tension de données
du tout ce jour-là vous pourrez nous
dire on n'a plus rien à voir avec le PC
chinois le gouvernement chinois et les
sociétés chinoises filiales de baidas
merci monsieur le rapporteur je recevais
hier une photographie de Norvège de ma
collègue qui visitait le chantier de
construction du centre de données
Norvège et c'était on était tous heureux
de le voir sortir de terre donc en fait
les projets se réalisent il y a déjà un
data center à Dublin qui est qui est
construit le deuxième sera bientôt
construit donc vous demandez une date
nous avons annoncé la date de 15 mois
voilà le délai de 15 mois on peut vous
dire dans 15 mois nous reviendrons vers
vous et normalement le projet Clover le
projet européen sera réalisé c'est
l'engagement que nous avons formulé
devant le ministre en charge du
numérique journal il y a quelques mois
vous construisez le centre
voilà et nous ne connais pas le nom de
la société avec lequel vous avez green
par exemple en Norvège Green Mountain et
le nom qui n'est pas communiqué pour
l'instant c'est le nom de du tiers de
confiance tout simplement parce que nous
sommes en négociation comme je disais
c'est un projet à un milliard 200
millions d'euros annuels donc c'est un
très gros projet et donc les discussions
commerciales se déroulent avec les
différentes entreprises et là aussi on
peut en tout cas s'engager à revenir
vers vous dans quelques mois en tout cas
dès que cette négociation sera terminée
voilà ce que je peux dire sur les délais
et sur
et sur le tiers de confiance
quant à l'accès aux données
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
dis toi qui est une plateforme de
communication donc en fait des données
doivent circuler mais quand on parle de
données il s'agit aussi de vidéos c'est
pas toujours des données personnelles
c'est donc quand vous avez acheté une
vidéo qui circule de temps en temps il
aura un mode privé en mode public donc
voilà il faut pouvoir aussi que des
métadonnées circulent quand vous sortez
une une fonctionnalité nouvelle il faut
pouvoir analyser sa performance donc ça
aussi c'est les données mais c'est pas
des données personnelles c'est juste
savoir combien de fois le filtre a été
utilisé donc c'est des données banales
des données produits
et puis parfois il faut corriger des
bugs quand vous avez un compte par
exemple vous avez une vidéo d'un seul
coup le compteur tombe à zéro c'est
qu'il y a un bug ce bug il faut il faut
pouvoir le régler donc ça peut être un
ingénieur qui est à Londres ça peut être
un ingénieur qui est à Singapour
voilà il peut être il peut être
n'importe où le tout c'est que le bug
soit autorisé et qui soit qui soit réglé
pardon et qui soit réglé par la personne
qui est autorisée à intervenir sur le
sur la machine
admettons que monsieur le rapporteur
vous ai dit dans sa question les données
personnelles si on doit reformuler donc
sur les données personnelles autrement
que dans les cas que vous avez décrit
quid parce que vraiment il y a pas de
transfert de données
la notion donnée personnelle est
elle-même une notion complexe donc je
préfère revenir par écrit vers vous à ce
sujet si vous me permettez
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
dans le futur est-ce que tout transfert
de données non autorisées sera
impossible ou tout transfert de données
tout court
donc comme je le disais une donnée en
fait ça peut être une information
banale j'allais dire qui porte sur
l'utilisation
d'un filtre d'une fonctionnalité
et donc ce type de données doit pouvoir
circuler d'un lieu à l'autre pour
pouvoir être analysé on est une
plateforme qui opère dans tous les pays
il faut donc
sauf en Chine effectivement et vous
transférez les données en Chine là je
vous parle par exemple d'un filtre
savoir combien de fois un filtre a été
téléchargé voilà ça c'est une c'est une
donnée qui n'est pas une donnée
personnelle mais il se peut qu'il soit
utile de faire circuler cette
information pour pouvoir améliorer le
produit
on a du mal à
comprendre je poursuis ma question vous
nous dit Tik Tok et douillet sont
désormais complètement séparés vos
réponses écrites vous nous dites Tik Tok
n'est pas disponible en Chine
continentale tandis que d'où il n'est
pas disponible en dehors de la Chine
continentale aucune donnée personnelle
n'est partagée entre ces deux entités
bon c'est la première chose vous nous
avez répondu c'est une réponse et votre
réponse à nous d'estimer si elle est
satisfaisante je continue pourtant selon
sa politique de confidentialité c'est
sur votre site Tik Tok transmet des
données à des entités en Chine
par ailleurs vous avez déclaré à la CNIL
transférer des données à une vingtaine
d'entreprises chinoises
si ce ne sont pas des entités de douille
puisque vous nous dites on travaille pas
avec douille est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire que sont ces entités
vous faites référence à donc un rapport
de la CNIL peut-être que je reviendrai
vous l'avez déclaré en 2020 je pense que
le rapport est public c'est pas il est
pas il est pas confidentiel d'accord
c'est aussi me permettez comme c'est un
fait très prestige je préfère à
l'analyser et revenir vers vous de
manière écrite sur ce sujet
je me demande si on voulait le problème
c'est qu'on vous l'a demandé dans nos
questions écrites et que vous nous avez
pas répondu et que aujourd'hui vous ne
répondez pas alors un jour ou l'autre la
commission d'enquête sera terminée et
encore pas reçu les réponses mais c'est
quand même
vous nous confirmer ce que vous avez dit
à la CNIL qu'il y a 20 entités en Chine
avec lesquels vous travaillez je préfère
répondre par écrit mais dans un délai
rapide si vous permettez
alors
vous nous dites que Tik Tok travaille
pas du tout en Chine et vous indiquez
dans
sur votre site ou dans les réponses que
nous avons faites je me rappelle plus
que Tik Tok je cite a été lancé en
Europe en 2018 les équipes produits et
ingénierie situées dans le monde entier
notamment aux États-Unis en Europe à
Singapour et en Chine travaille en
continu à son développement et son
évolution
vous parlez de Tik Tok donc est-ce qu'il
y a des employés Tik Tok en Chine là je
parle pas d'autres entités mais de Tik
Tok puisque vous parlez deux Tik Tok ou
bien ce que ce sont des employés
d'autres sociétés et notamment de
douiller
à ma connaissance je n'ai pas
connaissance d'employés de Tik Tok en
Chine mais c'est Amazon je me suis je
suis que chargé des relations
institutionnelles pour la France oui
mais vous rencontrez en permanence des
ministres des régulateurs des
commissaires européens etc je suppose
que toutes les questions qu'on vous
posent elles ont dû largement aux êtres
posés vous êtes directeur des relations
des relations publiques et
institutionnel
je parle c'est vous qui parlez d'équipe
produit et ingénierie
donc il y a des des équipes produits
ingénierie dans une dans des sociétés
qui ne sont pas TikTok puisque vous nous
dites en Chine et on sait pas lesquels
c'est pas très transparent
si vous avez des peut-être des questions
plus précises peut-être sur la
j'ai c'est vous qui êtes imprécis dans
votre réponse je peux pas vous en dire
plus puisque si vous dites je vous
recite je peux pas aller plus loin les
équipes produits ingénieries situées
dans le monde entier notamment aux
États-Unis en Europe à Singapour en
Chine travaille en continu à son
développement et son évolution c'est à
vous d'être plus précis moi je vous
demande quels sont ces équipes bon vous
me dites
revenir par écrit en tout cas comme je
vous indiquais ce qui est de vraiment
nous semble être le plus important c'est
de vérifier que notre nouveau système
soit parfaitement étanche et que les
accès soient autorisés du mot autorisés
pour des raisons très précises
peut-être tu voulais parler de données
alors après moi je voudrais passer aux
algorithmes
on va prendre les questions tout
ensemble et je me suis répondra
une question du coup je vais vous
laisser sur le sujet oui sur le sujet
bien sûr qui aussi avec l'actualité sur
notamment la proposition de loi
sur les influenceurs je voulais quand
même vous écouter sur comment vous allez
parce que vous monsieur m'amélioré vous
pose des questions sur le juridique vous
répondez opérationnel moi je vous pose
des questions sur l'opérationnel pour
vous amener vers le juridique
notamment sur comment vous allez mettre
en place vos équipes pour le contrôle
des promotions interdites et puis sur le
fait de
d'imposer la mention publicitaire
l'identification aussi des influenceurs
que pensez-vous d'ailleurs de de
d'imposer peut-être un badge sur ce que
c'est un influenceur à dimension
commerciale et un influenceur tout court
puisqu'il y a des influenceurs qui se
font ramirer d'autres non en
l'occurrence en tout cas ils font pas la
promotion totalement de produits voilà
je voulais avoir votre avis sur
sur l'actualité à ce niveau là et je
laisserai mes collègues sur le la
protection des données et peut-être vous
poser une question très simple pourquoi
avoir autant dépensé de milliards ou de
millions de dollars sur la stratégie du
lobbing si l'application est totalement
viable serait enfin si vous êtes serein
si vous n'avez pas de si vous avez rien
à cacher ou à vous avez envie d'être
transparent de A à Z enfin j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi il y a autant
d'argent de mis en place pour faire du
lobbing avec l'application Tik Tok
monsieur gatelin on va
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur je voulais
peut-être rebondir sur deux trois
informations que vous avez dit jusqu'à
présent il y a une chose qui m'a
beaucoup étonné vous avez dit nous
travaillons avec le pérenne avec
vigieome on les a auditionnés vous ne
travaillez pas avec eux c'est eux qui
vous demandent de coopérer et de donner
des informations c'est pas une
coopération je dirais de père à père
c'est des instances des autorités qui
vous demandent des informations et moi
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'ils en ont
certaines mais qui n'ont pas tout ce qui
voudrait je tiens à être précis sur plan
c'est mon petit un autre aspect vous
avez évoqué j'ai été
impressionné par le volume
concernant le trust and safety en
Irlande vous parlez de 40000 personnes
je suis un peu étonné parce que il
existe et vous l'avez dit un peu plus
tard un choft trust and safety Amérique
qui était dirigé d'ailleurs par erican
qui a quitté ses fonctions suite à des
position notamment aux États-Unis où il
a dit qu'il voulait pas être un sky
Skype goat c'est à dire un bouc
émissaire
son unité aux États-Unis c'est 1400
personnes donc à 1400 personnes pour
faire de la modération aux États-Unis
qui ont des premiers marchés de TikTok
il y en aurait 40 000 en Europe donc
j'ai du mal à voir comme
c'est 40000 mondialement
il se trouve que le responsable mondial
de cette entité est en Irlande voilà
c'est ça mais d'accord
parce que c'est un aspect important pour
comprendre aussi l'emploi parce qu'on a
très peu d'éléments sur quels sont en
dehors de bindens proprement dit et
douille qu'elle est aujourd'hui le
volume d'employés quand je vois dans les
sites américains quand on travaille
justement trust and safety c'est une
rémunération annuelle il y a deux ans
entre 60 et 60000 65000 dollars par an
ça fait quand même beaucoup d'argent
d'avoir une masse salariale un peu
chargée mais on reviendra je pense plus
tard sur la question des des logiques et
des équilibres économiques alors
évidemment quand on est un groupe il y a
des logiques de mutualisation
j'imagine que on parlait des données des
transferts de données c'est une chose il
y a une mutualisation technologique et
ça je peux comprendre qu'il y a des
échanges compris avec la société mère il
y a une question quand on parle de trust
and safety
on nous parle en fait de modération des
contenus ce qui est quelque chose de
très important mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est quelle protection et
quelle cybersécurité des plateformes
parce que une des choses qui est
importante et on le sait chaque année
dans tous les pays et toutes les
plateformes quelle qu'elle soit elles
font l'objet d'actane et feront l'objet
de vol de données quel est
le niveau de cybersécurité de Tik Tok
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait l'objet
d'attaque notamment en France quel est
le nombre de ces attaques et est-ce
qu'on vous a alors je sais que c'est
toujours compliqué en terme d'image déjà
voler des données on nous en vole dans
des grandes bases de données françaises
là il s'agit pas de savoir si vous
transférez volontairement vers
l'étranger vers tel ou tel pays des
données mais quel est votre capacité de
résistance au vol et c'est quelque chose
de massif à corps russe ou autre
extrêmement important et donc est-ce que
vous êtes totalement sécurisé vous
pouvez garantir que vos données ne sont
pas volées ou en tous les cas qui sont
très protégés et surtout est-ce que vous
faites concrètement l'objet d'attaque
comme tous les autres groupes de quelle
manière vous avez évoqué la coopération
avec lensis généralement demande aux
grandes entreprises
y compris les entreprises privées
aujourd'hui de déclarer les attaques qui
sont faites est-ce que vous avez procédé
à des signalements et à des déclarations
voilà ce sont mes questions pour
l'instant merci
sur les données justement on va prendre
la question madame pourrait également
puisqu'on est sur le sujet
vous allez répondre de manière groupée
très rapidement Tik Tok est venu
infliger en France par la Commission
nationale de l'informatique et des
libertés donc la CNIL mi-janvier une
amende de 5 millions d'euros car les
utilisateurs ne peuvent y refuser les
cookies les traceurs informatiques la
plateforme a aussi été condamnée au
Royaume-Uni à une amende de plus de 12
millions d'euros début avril pour
l'utilisation illégale de donner liées
aux enfants donc je voudrais savoir si
c'est condamnation conduite Tik Tok a
opéré des adaptations des évolutions
pour se mettre en conformité puis
j'imagine qu'avant d'arriver à la
condamnation il y a eu des signalements
il y a eu des alertes je voulais savoir
pourquoi est-ce que Tik Tok a vite tardé
si Tik Tok s'est mis en conformité ou à
opérer des changements pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle avait tardé à se mettre en
conformité combien de temps il a eu
entre les premiers les premières alertes
lancées à Tik Tok et
l'amande qui a été infligée je vous
remercie
alors merci monsieur le Président et
merci Madame sénatrice et Monsieur
sénateur donc je vais répondre dans
peut-être dans l'ordre donc sur les sur
les influenceurs donc nous avons
évidemment participé aux travaux qui ont
été conduits au sein du ministre du
ministère des Finances piloté par le
ministre lui-même d'ailleurs et qui se
sont articulés ensuite avec la
proposition de loi
Végéta de la porte puisqu'on a eu un
rapprochement de plusieurs propositions
de loi on a salué d'ailleurs le
caractère très constructif et de cette
démarche et le résultat final de la loi
pense et tout à fait intéressant on
avait déjà mis en oeuvre en fait chez
Tik Tok des dispositifs d'une part pour
restreindre la publicité sur certains
produits donc on a notre liste de
produits interdits de publicités et déjà
très importante chez Tik Tok le sujet
par exemple de la de la chirurgie
esthétique avait été mentionnée y
compris par le ministre et donc ça fait
partie des sujets sur lesquels on ne
peut pas faire de publicité chez Tik Tok
comme les produits pharmaceutiques le
tabac l'alcool etc et on veille aussi à
ce que les publicités ciblées ne soient
pas
dirigé vers des publics mineurs donc ça
c'est aussi quelque un engagement que
nous avons pris avant même le vote de la
loi
nous interdisons aussi les jeux d'argent
les paris sportifs voilà donc tous ces
ensuite sur le sur le signalement des
vidéos faisant l'objet d'une promotion
donc nous avons déjà cette
fonctionnalité qui est qui est demandé
et d'ailleurs même quand un créateur
présente un produit de marque dans une
vidéo
quand l'algorithme détecte cette vidéo
on lui propose spontanément de cibler sa
vidéo comme s'agissant d'une vidéo
faisant l'objet d'une promotion voilà
donc ça c'est des sujets sur lesquels on
est très attentif et on veillera aussi à
travailler en
bonne int
avec la dgcdf qui qui maintenant a lancé
des programmes de contrôle pour que
cette loi soit pleinement appliquée
alors je n'ai pas bien saisi en fait
quand vous parliez des milliards si
c'était le si ça faisait référence au
projet que j'ai évoqué parce que
nous dépensons pas des milliards en
lobbying mais nous dépensons des
milliards en création de centre de
données de ta question c'est sur le
lobbying j'imagine par rapport aux
chiffres que vous nous avez donné dans
les questionnaires sur vos dépenses de
d'accord de relation publique
mais c'est aussi des milliards c'est
pour ça que je comprenais pas et oui
donc non non on est très loin de ces
ordres de grandeur
donc je n'ai pas de commentaires
particuliers à faire si ce n'est que
comme n'importe quelle entreprise nous
avons une direction des relations
institutionnelles et que nous faisons ce
travail d'aller échanger et compris avec
vous ce matin et aussi dans d'autres
commissions nous avons toujours répondu
présent dès lors qu'il y a eu des
demandes d'audition parlementaires sur
tous les sujets donc voilà je pense
qu'on est dans une démarche de
coopération de transparence et que c'est
ça qui fait aussi l'objet de ces de ses
dépenses c'est de préparer au mieux
aussi c'est ces interventions et c'est
et ces discussions
ensuite sur la question de la sécurité
la cybersécurité alors on cherche
justement à établir des relations avec
l'ancien on n'a pas encore eu de
rendez-vous mais on espère avoir un
rendez-vous justement pour se présenter
pour présenter les projets Clover et
pour pouvoir indiquer que on est très
ouvert à ce que l'ancien puisse faire
des tests pour vérifier la robustesse de
nos dispositifs donc voilà on est on est
vraiment très ouvert à cette discussion
et effectivement comme vous le disais
nous sommes ce n'est pas un choix mais
nous cohérons comme nous devons le faire
avec vigilum et avec le pérenne et je
pense que ce qui nous manquait jusqu'ici
pour pouvoir répondre à toutes les
questions c'était les API les API qui
permettent d'interroger par exemple nos
algorithmes et c'est pourquoi nous
sommes en train de développer ces API et
que ça permettra aussi de tester
davantage de fonctionnalités ou de
naviguer dans davantage de contenu
voilà donc sur le volume des attaques
des attaques ce sont des voilà des
données que je pense qu'il vaut mieux
échanger de manière confidentielle si
vous me permettez mais on peut échanger
tout à fait sur ces questions là
et enfin sur la vente de la CNIL si je
peux la dessus de nombreux comment dire
de nombreuses plateformes ou géants du
web comme on dit en matière de
cybersécurité il y a
comment dire un principe qui est assez
partagé par tout le monde et je pense
que lentilles vous le dira c'est le fait
qu'il faut faire circuler l'information
sur la question des attaques
c'est-à-dire que la même façon que c'est
pas honteuse d'attraper la grippe ou de
d'avoir un accident de la vie de la même
façon quand on est attaqué le plus sûr
c'est de bien partager l'information de
le faire de manière très transversale
entre responsable et d'ailleurs dans le
dans la loi de programmation militaire
il y a des obligations pour les éditeurs
logiciels de faire connaître leurs
failles de la manière la plus rapide
possible je glisse au passage ne
serait-ce qu'en terme de relation
publique oui c'est il y a un caractère
confidentiel mais pour autant vis-à-vis
des personnes des personnes concernées
il faut faire connaître les attaques et
j'espère que vous faites connaître vos
failles de sécurité quand elles ont été
constatées comme tout un chacun aux
responsables
tout à fait d'ailleurs de communiquons
d'ores et déjà je lisais tout à l'heure
sur les les attaques on va dire sur la
plateforme c'est-à-dire des voilà des
tentatives de coordonnées de disséminer
des contenus visant à une des
informations manifeste notamment à
l'occasion de d'élection et là nous
avons communiqué sur ce qui s'est passé
en Allemagne par exemple nous avons des
mots clés 3000 comptes qui diffusaient
des fausses informations ou au Kenya
aussi où nous avons pu le faire
découvrir ce type de de réseau donc
voilà de ce point de vue là nous
communiquons
et peut-être un mot sur donc la bande
effectivement de la CNIL donc nous
avions déjà comme poser la question nous
avions effectivement déjà pris la mesure
de cette de cette de cette faille qu'il
fallait corriger
s'agissant des cookies et en fait il
s'agissait de non pas de l'application
TikTok qui est évidemment le principal
outil d'accès à TikTok c'est
l'application sur les sur les app store
il s'agissait de la web app c'est-à-dire
de on peut aussi accéder à Tik Tok par
internet et il est vrai que comme c'est
plus mineur en fait les gens vont plutôt
utiliser l'application je pense qu'il y
a une négligence sur le fait que les
utilisateurs de Tik Tok par le web
n'était pas forcément informé des
cookies qui pouvaient exister sur la
plateforme donc ça a été corrigé et
c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs que
l'amende de la CNIL alors certes c'est
c'est un montant important mais c'est
vrai que d'autres
d'autres plateformes ont eu des amendes
bien plus importantes parfois plus de 50
millions d'euros donc de ce point de vue
là on pense qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a agi
avec avec rapidité
et bien entendu on est dans un processus
d'amélioration constante dans tous les
domaines y compris ce domaine
l'utilisation des données des enfants en
Angleterre
on est vraiment très vigilant justement
à ce que les publics mineurs soient le
mieux protégé possible qui soit pas
exposé à certaines publicités ou
et que les contenus qu'il voit aussi
soient des contenus les plus adaptés à
leur âge
sur un porteur
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
poser revenir au problème de
l'algorithme ou des algorithmes
nous avions posé la question
qui détient la propriété intellectuelle
due aux dés algorithmes au niveau
mondial
vous n'avez pas répondu
nous vous avons posé la question y
a-t-il un algorithme ou des portions
d'algorithme commun entre Tik Tok et
douille vous avez répondu de façon
particulièrement brève il n'y a pas
d'algorithme commun ni de partie
d'algorithmes communs entre Tik Tok et
douillet
pourtant le PDG de Tik Tok monsieur zut
a déclaré dans son audition au Sénat
américain que bail d'un se traduit dans
sa développer les algorithmes à la fois
pour douiller une étiquette et par
conséquent sommes of the same under line
basic technology building blocks sont
utilisés par les deux produits
en outre la Chine par la voix de son
secrétaire d'État au Commerce a
récemment affirmé que la Chine refusait
la vente de Tik Tok au motif qu'elle ne
voulait pas perdre ses technologies
elle a ajouté les technologies
algorithmiques utilisées par TikTok et
par douillet à la liste des technologies
inexportables sans l'autorisation du
gouvernement chinois
bloquant et
une éventuelle vente de Tik Tok a des
étrangers
comment expliquer cette déclaration si
Tik Tok et douillet sont totalement
séparés et si Tik Tok est totalement
indépendant du gouvernement chinois
donc monsieur le rapporteur les
algorithmes sont en effet différenciés
entre des deux des deux applications et
donc ce sont des équipes spécifiques qui
développent l'algorithme de
recommandations de Tik Tok
et comme indiqué le la chaîne
capitalistique et juridique qui descend
de bindens à Tik Tok
doit permettre de de faire en sorte
qu'il n'est pas de pression qui soit
exercée à l'encontre de la plateforme
atiktok ensuite je pense que ce qui est
important par rapport à vos
préoccupations légitimes c'est que des
algorithmes soient
auditables qu'on puisse vérifier qu'il
n'y a pas de biais algorithmique ni dans
le sens de la censure de la propagande
ou de la désinformation
et de ce point de vue là nous
développons ces API qui vont permettre
aux autorités de régulation aux
chercheurs la communauté scientifique
d'interroger ces algorithmes et de
vérifier qu'il n'y a pas de des billets
qui soit contraire à l'intérêt général
j'allais dire
alors je vous repose la question qui
détient la propriété intellectuelle due
ou des algorithmes au niveau mondial
peut-être de revenir par écrit sur cette
question en tout cas il semble logique
que ce soit que ce soit by dance qui
soit propriétaire de ces de ces
algorithmes
ça n'a pas l'air d'être la vie du
gouvernement chinois puisque le
gouvernement chinois dit les
technologies algorithmiques utilisées
par Tik Tok et du gin sont des
technologies chinoises des des
propriétés intellectuelles chinoises et
elles sont inexportables sans
l'autorisation du gouvernement chinois
donc il semble bien en tout cas la vie
du gouvernement chinois c'est que la
propriété intellectuelle elle appartient
à une société chinoise
je n'ai pas de commentaires à faire sur
sur des déclarations de quelques
gouvernements que ce soit monsieur
rapporteur
mais vous vous pensez que si vous voulez
vendre si un jour pas seulement sous les
agents du gouvernement américain mais
ceci un jour
soucis de chou et ses associés voulaient
vendre Tik Tok
vous constatez qu'apparemment ça posera
des problèmes avec le gouvernement
chinois et que par conséquent eux vous
pouvez pas
prononcer sur le gouvernement chinois
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui dans la
situation actuelle Tik Tok et coincé
s'il veut
opérer des opérations et notamment des
opérations qui ont impliquerait
l'utilisation de son algorithme
ce que je peux dire c'est que Tik Tok et
le groupe Aiden c'est dans une logique
de développement de poursuivre sur sa
lancée de continuer à développer de
nouveaux produits nouvelle
fonctionnalités et que tout est mis en
mesure tout est fait de telle sorte que
ces algorithmes puissent être auditables
et que s'il y a des préoccupations
légitimes que ces algorithmes puissent
être biaisés manipulés que on puisse
apporter toute réponse de nature à vous
rassurer sur ce point
ou sur d'autres sujets comme on parlait
aussi de du temps de
du côté renfermement des bulles le
rythmique qu'on puisse aussi vous
apporter des réponses sur ce point
c'est-à-dire voilà tout ce qui peut
concerner
des effets néfastes de ces algorithmes
qu'on puisse apporter des clarifications
qui souhaitent nature à vous rassurer
sur le fait qu'ils sont utilisés non pas
pour développer de l'addiction ou de la
toxicité mais au contraire pour
permettre à nos utilisateurs de
s'épanouir
de se divertir de s'instruire et de
communiquer les uns avec les autres dans
un plein souci de liberté d'expression
moi je vous parle propriété et notamment
la propriété intellectuelle
l'utilisation qui vous fait juste une
remarque au passage les régulateurs et
plusieurs de nos interlocuteurs nous ont
dit que les API de Tik Tok aujourd'hui
étaient embryonnaire par rapport aux
autres sociétés par rapport aux autres
plateformes et que les autres
plateformes sont pas totalement
transparentes mais qu'elles ont des API
qui permettent pas mal pas mal d'accès
ok vous nous promettez des API qui
permettront de vérifier les utilisations
mais moi je vous parle de propriété
aujourd'hui le gouvernement chinois dit
alors est-ce que ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui quelle est la part de de
l'algorithme quelle est la part des de
l'ingénierie sur l'algorithme qui est
effectué en Chine ou qui est effectué
ailleurs mais apparemment une bonne
partie l'algorithme chinois au départ
l'algor commun avec entre deux inédits
donc au départ il est séparé mais il
semble être majoritairement
utilisé par des ingénieurs d'une société
je sais pas laquelle chinoise vous devez
quand même savoir avec quelle société
chinoise vous travaillez puisque vous
travaillez avec des Chinoises vous
l'avez dit vous-même Tic-Toc l'a dit à
la CNIL elle l'a reconnu dans des
auditions vous devez quand même en tant
que directeur des affaires
institutionnels et des affaires
publiques savoir avec quelle société
chinoise le TikTok travail s'agissant de
l'algorithme que vous évoquiez
l'algorithme de recommandation je sais
qu'il y a des équipes d'ingénieurs
au Royaume-Uni il y en a aux États-Unis
il y en a Singapour
voilà donc c'est ce que je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui et par ailleurs je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres
entreprises de technologie beaucoup
d'entreprises occidentales qui ont aussi
des ingénieurs en Chine et je ne crois
pas que ça pose de difficultés la
question en revanche que vous
préoccupation que vous exprimez sur
l'intégrité des systèmes ça bien entendu
nous l'adressons et nous l'adressons par
de dispositifs de sécurisation de des
données des Européens et par
l'auditabilité des algorithmes vous
dites que les API sont embryonnaires
c'est vrai nous sommes en train de les
créer nous sommes une société qui
n'existait pas il y a 6 ans et donc nous
sommes en train de développer ces API et
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que le
responsable d'entité très sainte et le
premier à dire il faut que nous soyons
le plus ouvert possible et que nos
systèmes puissent être au
alors à la question 8 que nous avions
posées portant sur les éventuels
systèmes d'information commun entre Tik
Tok et douille vous faites une réponse
imprécise vous répondez sur les données
des utilisateurs et puis vous indiquer
que Tik Tok utilise sa propre plateforme
de collaboration professionnelle qui
s'appelle la
elle a RK utilisé par tous les employés
de baidens vous utilisez donc un
logiciel de messagerie spécifique
le New York Times a indiqué le 24 mai
dernier c'est récent que les messages
des employés de Tik Tok sur la
messagerie d'entreprise l'arc était
largement accessible à des employés en
Chine notre question reformuler et donc
est-ce que l'arc est utilisé en Chine
par les employés de douille quels sont
les messages des employés de Tik Tok qui
sont accessibles aux employés de Douilly
pourquoi les employés Tic-Toc et
douillets n'utilisent la même messagerie
semble-t-il sans droit d'accès
particulier sans sans restriction
d'accès particuliers si Tik Tok et
douillet n'ont rien en commun
alors si vous permettez Monsieur
rapporteur en fait l'arc c'est une c'est
une application que vous pouvez
télécharger vous-même c'est une c'est
une c'est une messagerie comme il en
existe un grand nombre c'est un peu
comme teams zoom ou
slack aussi voilà donc c'est quelque
chose d'assez c'est un banal outils
d'échange
donc voilà je ne vois pas de
particularité propre à l'arc par rapport
à d'autres outils bureautiques non mais
ce qui me pose problème c'est pas
l'outil c'est le fait que les employés
de Tik Tok et d'urine partagent
allègrement la plateforme la messagerie
l'arc
s'il y a pas aucun rapport entre Tik Tok
et du in c'est quand même un peu
surprenant
écoutez en tout cas moi j'utilise mes
collègues j'utilise l'arc pour échanger
au sein de titoga SAS ou pour échanger
avec nos collègues de Tik Tok en Europe
mais voilà nous n'avons pas d'autres
usages
que je ne sais pas si votre réponse est
non exhaustive ou s'il y a trois petits
points pour échanger avec des collègues
de Tik Tok SS de Tik Tok Europe
mais comme comme les deux les entités
sont très séparées nous nos échanges
c'est au sein de Tik Tok donc c'est
voilà on peut échanger aussi avec
l'Amérique latine avec avec les
États-Unis bien entendu avec qui nous
avons des réunions mais c'est
vraiment les réunions se font au sein de
l'entité TikTok là dans votre téléphone
sur vos sur votre application là que je
ne connaissais pas vous n'avez pas de
discussion ouverte avec des des
collègues de bague dance en Chine
pas de douillet en tout cas pas à ma
connaissance d'accord c'est vous qui
savez c'est dans votre poche donc la
réponse est non la réponse est mais non
après parfois on peut échanger avec
quelqu'un on sait pas exactement d'où il
ressort enfin quel est son entité
juridique
non mais d'accord donc j'entends bien
mais ma question
que vous échangez avec quelqu'un sans
savoir qu'en ce moment il est pendant
deux mois à Shanghai j'en suis pas à ce
niveau de de comment dire de suspicion
mais vous n'échangez pas avec des
responsables d'identifier chinois sur
l'arc je ne pense pas on a pu échanger
avec des des collègues de picots puisque
Pico est dans le groupe aussi c'est un
qui crée des casques de réalité
virtuelle mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
doux c'est c'est une autre entité
d'accord
les centres de données dont vous venez
de nous parler
est-ce qu'ils utiliseront les mêmes
logiciels américains qu'actuellement et
qui sont immatriculés aux États-Unis à
savoir Google cloud Amazon webs et
Microsoft et jeux
c'est une question qui à nos yeux est
importante puisque elle permet de
déterminer la soumission éventuelle au
Cloud Act américain
alors Monsieur rapporteur l'idée c'est
précisément d'avoir un système différent
entre les États-Unis et l'Europe et que
en Europe on puisse travailler dans la
mesure du possible avec des entreprises
européennes
je peux pas divulguer d'autres d'autres
noms de marque dans une enceinte
publique mais je propose de revenir vers
vous par écrit dans la mesure où on peut
transmettre des informations plus
précises sur ce point
merci alors je vous repose pour la
deuxième fois la question
à laquelle je ne crois pas que vous ayez
répondu qui détient la propriété
intellectuelle due au désalgorithmes de
TikTok au niveau mondial
sur cette question je préfère également
si vous me permettez de revenir par vers
vous par écrit
ce que je peux faire ici à mon niveau
c'est vous apporter des précisions sur
la manière dont ces algorithmes sont
utilisés la manière dont fonctionne
notre dispositif de modération la
manière dont nous pouvons par des API
audités ces algorithmes mais sur la
question de la propriété intellectuelle
elle-même c'est une question trop
technique pour vous répondre ici
juste pour préciser compléter la
question puisque le Royaume-Uni joue un
rôle important dans votre installation
depuis le brexit et la sortie même s'il
y a des accords de prolongation du
système de la propriété intellectuelle
qui était posée par l'Union européenne
on note un dépôt extrêmement massif de
nouveaux patins de nouvelles licences au
Royaume-Uni donc est-ce que vous avez
protégé déposer pour le niveau européen
ou en tous les cas dans le cadre de
votre entreprise
les si vous pouvez nous renseigner sur
les démarches qui sont en termes de
protection justement de la
de la propriété intellectuelle qu'est-ce
qui est fait au Royaume-Uni parce que
c'est une question qu'on se pose puisque
logiquement le Royaume-Uni continue à
poursuivre les règles qui avaient été
posées par l'Union européenne et
parallèlement on voit un double système
se mettre en place et le Royaume-Uni
fonctionne actuellement à des failles
dans les accords qu'ils ont mis en place
avec l'Union européenne donc ça
m'intéresserait de savoir si Tik Tok ou
les compagnies qui sont liées ont
procédé à ces dépôts tout à fait légaux
puisque ça appartient aux droits
britanniques mais au droit britannique
uniquement
merci c'est
je reviendrai vers vous effectivement
avec plus d'informations sur sur ce
point ce que je peux dire en tout cas
c'est que Tik Tok se développe beaucoup
en Europe continentale nous ouvrons des
bureaux régulièrement dans un plus grand
nombre de pays on a commencé avec
l'Allemagne
la France
Bruxelles et maintenant nous aurons des
bureaux dans d'autres pays de l'Europe
continentale en Europe du Sud notamment
[Musique]
en réponse à la question 35 du deuxième
questionnaire envoyé vous indiquez que
l'expression amélioration de
l'expérience utilisateur ne figure pas
dans votre politique de confidentialité
elle y est pourtant bien présente
puisque vous utilisez le terme optimisé
l'expérience utilisateur comme intérêt
légitime pour partager à des tiers des
informations sur les utilisateurs c'est
une expression qui reste très vague
qu'est-ce qu'elle recouvre concrètement
est-ce que l'utilisateur a selon vous
conscience qu'il partage ses
informations dans ce but très général
alors à ma connaissance on partage pas
de données avec des tiers
sauf dans le cadre des API que nous
sommes en train de mettre en place en
conformité avec le DSA
je pense que vous l'utilisez cette
phrase dans les échanges de données dans
la politique de confidentialité dans les
échanges de données avec des sociétés
étrangères
sans préciser évidemment
vous dites il y a des sociétés aux
États-Unis à Malaisie à Singapour en
Chine avec laquelle nous travaillons et
parmi les sujets à travailler optimiser
l'expérience utilisateur
je propose là aussi de revenir par écrit
c'est un point très technique ça vous
permettez Monsieur rapporteur
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où en
est la procédure sur l'enquête
réglementaire initiée par la difficile
irlandaise
portant sur la conformité de Tik Tok
Airlande avec le rgpd dans le cadre du
traitement des données personnelles
d'utilisateur âgés de moins de 18 ans
entre le 29 juillet 2020 et le 31
décembre 2020
ça fait deux ans que la même plus de
deux ans que la procédure dure je pense
qu'elle touche à sa fin j'ai entendu
dire que la DPC Prométhée ou en tout cas
envisager une réponse une définitive
pour l'été mais avant la réponse
définitive il y a des transferts entre
il y a des échanges entre
j'imagine la difficile et votre société
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où on
en est
alors je n'ai pas d'informations à
partager à cet égard sur le rapporteur
mais
seule chose que je puisse faire c'est
difficile oui bien sûr je pense que ce
sera ce sera connu
Tik Tok pousse les contenus et notamment
j'utilise ce terme parce que il circule
poussent les conduits notamment de la
chaîne du festival du livre pour l'aider
à gagner en visibilité c'est un article
dans
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de mots
comment procède-t-on aux poussettes
combien y a-t-il de pousseur si c'est
des je pense que c'est des interventions
humaines en France et quelle est leur
marge de manoeuvre et à qui est-ce
qu'ils ont réfèrent
merci monsieur le rapporteur je pense
que ma collègue Marlène mesure que oui
moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la proportion des vidéos qui font
l'objet d'une mise en avant
éditoriale et très faible on a fait un
test sur les quelques mois et on était à
0,06 %. donc c'est vraiment marginal
mais c'est évidemment des contenus que
vous citiez le livre c'est plutôt des
contenus justement qu'on met en avant
pour des raisons éducatives culturelles
on est on a très à coeur évidemment de
jouer notre rôle citoyen et de pouvoir
mettre en avant des produits qui
intéressent et des contenus qui
intéressent le plus nos communautés
donc le livre c'est vrai que c'est une
très belle histoire puisque le
mot dièse booktok
est à plus de 150 milliards de vues et
dans le monde et c'est une c'est un
phénomène au départ très organique c'est
à dire c'est une
américaine qui a commencé à faire une
chronique littéraire sur sur Tik Tok
d'un livre qui partait sur Achille donc
un ticket grec et c'est devenu une vidéo
virale et depuis lors on a beaucoup de
d'utilisateurs de tous les âges qui font
des chroniques littéraires sur Tik Tok
et c'est vrai que nous avons encouragé
ce mouvement en France d'une part parce
que la lecture le livre sont une cause
nationale des critée comme tel par la
France et nous avions aussi rencontré le
ministre de l'éducation nationale à
l'époque Jean-Michel Blanquer qui qui
souhaitait que voilà les jeunes qui vont
vers les écrans puissent aussi revenir
vers le livre et la lecture et donc
voilà ça ça fait partie effectivement
des choses que nous avons encouragées on
a même mis en place une interface
apprendre sur Tik Tok qui a déjà 200
millions de vues alors qu'on vient à
peine de la Lancer et qui permet de se
cultiver sur Tik Tok donc c'est ça ça
fait partie des des contenus qui sont
mis en avant parfois par le fait de
créer cette page avec des onglets
langue étrangère histoire
culture et c'est on pense que ça
correspond aussi à un appétit très fort
de une curiosité très forte de nos
utilisateurs si vous permettez pour vous
permettre de répondre plus précisément à
la question de ne se rapporter je vais
faire le candide
cette responsable des affaires publiques
donc je pense que là pour le coup c'est
vraiment vous qui êtes à la manœuvre ce
serait normal quand vous êtes
j'en sais rien moi une entreprise locale
ou une collectivité vous avez la presse
locale qui tend à autre vient vous
démarcher en disant tiens pour votre
festival de je ne festival annuel le je
ne sais quoi au votre salon on peut
faire un partenariat c'est à dire que il
y aura des reportages sur lesquels vous
n'avez pas la main bien évidemment d'un
point de vue rédactionnel mais on
s'engage à faire pendant une semaine un
reportage dans la page départementale ou
régional sur le salon voilà pour amener
de la visibilité ça existe depuis que le
monde est monde
j'imagine dans le cas d'espèce que à un
moment vous allez voir le Salon du livre
ou le salon du livre vient vers vous et
vous dit et là je voudrais que vous me
répondiez concrètement là c'est pas
combien d'articles j'ai par jour si vous
disent le partenariat c'est que
nous on s'engage à promouvoir
l'application à l'intérieur du Salon du
livre ou l'usage ou le mot dièse booktok
ou que sais-je mais en échange de quoi
vous vous allez pousser le contenu sur
le salon du livre donc ma question est
simple quel est l'objet du marché
c'est-à-dire que vous vous leur dites il
y a bien un moment le journal qui vient
vous voir il vous dit vous aurez un
article par jour vous vous dites quoi
vous serez poussé à hauteur de tant de
vidéos ou l'algorithme sera je veux pas
dire forcé mais l'algorithme sera amené
à mettre du contenu sur le salon du
livre dans sur tant de fils là je pense
que vous pouvez répondre concrètement
sur ces sujets là c'est ça relève
vraiment de la direction contenue et
opération donc je pense que Marlène
masure vous répondra alors vous avez
quelqu'un de la direction contenu et
opération qui vient avec vous quand vous
rencontrez les personnes d'un salon ou
du ou d'un festival il faut bien que
vous puissiez leur répondre concrètement
parce que que de manière aimable autour
d'un café vous puissiez vous dire que
tout le monde adore la littérature le
cinéma les formats courts et le
surréalisme nouvelle version j'entends
c'est très aimable on est tous friand de
tout ça mais il y a un moment où la
personne elle doit rendre compte elle
aussi à son conseil d'administration il
faut qu'il puisse dire à un moment le
partenariat avec Tik Tok nous a permis
de par exemple le Salon du livre ils ont
dit ça nous a permis d'accroître la
visibilité de tant pour cent vous avez
même des chaînes d'information j'ai été
très étonné que des rédactions encore
que ces derniers temps on a appris que
les bandeaux parfois c'était assez
aléatoire sur qui décidait du contenu
mais on a vu des bandeaux sur une chaîne
d'information en continu qui disait
littéralement cette année le Salon du
livre a eu tant de visiteurs en plus
grâce à un partenariat Tik Tok je ça
c'est de la bonne c'est de la belle
ouvrage comme on dit ma grand-mère c'est
assez efficace à la fin c'est ce qui est
marqué sur les bandeaux de chaîne
d'information quand vous démarchez ces
gens-là ou quand ils viennent vous voir
mais tout ça n'a rien de ça là c'est
comme je vous l'ai exposé ça existe dans
la presse locale il y a bien un moment
où au-delà du fait de se dire c'est
formidable on va ouvrir pour la culture
tout ça ensemble il y a bien un moment
où quelqu'un leur dit et je pense que
c'est fait partie de votre boulot ou
d'avoir ces personnes avec vous si on a
le partenariat vous serez poussé de
telle façon vous serez vu par tant de
personnes en plus que vous vous ne
sachiez pas ouvrir le capot de
l'ordinateur ou de l'algorithme et faire
tout ça je ça je l'entends bien c'est
parce qu'on vous demande mais quels sont
les quel est l'objet du marché
sur le Festival du Livre de Paris on
peut prendre cet exemple je pense
d'ailleurs qu'on a dû vous transmettre
le contrat de partenariat les choses
étaient assez simples c'est le festival
du livre qui nous a proposé c'est
effectivement ce partenariat c'est son
but c'était effectivement d'accroître sa
communication en direction des jeunes
publiques et effectivement ça a été
plutôt suivi des faits puisque en tout
cas il a été constaté que quasiment 45%
je crois de la fréquentation de du total
du service a été des jeunes de moins de
25 ans mais entre les deux c'est parce
que vous vous avez bien travaillé donc
c'est quoi bien travailler vous pousser
combien de contenu sur combien de fils
comment ça marche donc le contenu de ce
partenariat en tout cas c'était d'avoir
un espace au sein de de du festival du
livre pour pouvoir accueillir des
créateurs et favoriser la rencontre avec
des auteurs et pouvoir faire des vidéos
qui ensuite étaient projetées sur Tik
Tok mais Marion je pense on pourra
rentrer davantage dans le détail mais
généralement
je ne pense pas qu'on rentre dans ce
degré de de détails c'est simplement que
le hashtag le mot dièse booktok est un
mot # qui est très populaire en soi et
qui peut faire l'objet d'une
éditorialisation particulière sous forme
d'une page dédiée
à la littérature et qui va de temps en
temps mettre en avant des des créateurs
des contenus voilà mais
l'essentiel c'est ça la beauté de la
chose c'est que c'est le phénomène est
très organique ce sont vraiment c'est un
écosystème où certains types de contenus
sont très demandés et donc ça crée de
l'envie pour d'autres créateurs de se
lancer aussi dans ce type de contenu
non c'était juste pour prolonger la
question donc ça veut dire qu'il y a une
extrême réactivité c'est dans le cadre
du partenariat vous faites vous faites
venir des créateurs TikTok
in situ et que ça provoque un afflux ça
veut dire que les gens sont dans une
réactivité quasi immédiate c'est pas
quelque chose qui est monté en amont sur
la plateforme TikTok c'est la production
de contenu qui suscite une réactivité
très forte c'est ça et donc dans ce
cadre là est-ce que vous utilisez par
exemple dans le cadre de l'algorithme de
la géolocalisation parce que excusez-moi
si vous habitez à 500 km de de Paris le
Salon du livre vous allez pas vous
déplacer parce qu'il y a un créateur qui
a fait la promotion et venir donc
visiter le dit salon
après alors c'est vrai qu'entre
quel est le déterminant et quel est le
reflet puisqu'on est aussi le reflet de
la société une plateforme et refait la
société moi je pense qu'il y a un
mouvement peut-être plus ancien déjà de
que les de retour à la lecture et au
livre de la part des jeunes il y a
d'autres effets il y a ce que vous
proposez est-ce que vous proposez aux
gens du Salon du livre quand vous dites
le partenariat consiste également à ce
qu'on pousse les contenus de manière
géocalisée sur les gens susceptibles de
se dire tiens demain on va son nom du
livre ça n'a rien de sale vous savez que
la presse locale il vous propose d'écrit
de d'envoyer
d'envoyer un truc particulier à tout
leur nouveau abonnés dans votre
département de l'année on vous demande
simplement est-ce que vous est-ce que
par exemple vous êtes en mesure
commercialement peut-être que Madame
nous répondra cet après midi de dire et
bien vous aurez l'assurance que sur
telle zone géographique on poussera le
Salon du livre à tel moment du fait de
la géologue de la géolocalisation des
abonnés oui ou non moi ce que je sais
mon niveau c'est que la géolocalisation
est très peu développée ée sur
l'application mais je préfère que
effectivement que ce soit marine mesure
qui vous réponde sur ce point-là
Tik Tok devait remettre en janvier à la
commissaire européenne verra Jean Nova
un rapport sur la désinformation sur sa
plateforme est-ce que le rapport a été
remis et est-ce que Madame Genova a
donné une opinion sur ce rapport merci
Monsieur rapporteur effectivement nous
avons adhéré de manière volontaire au
code européen de lutte contre la
désinformation et nous avons remis notre
premier rapport à la Commission
européenne nous avons dans ce rapport
divulgué de 2500 données de 1500
informations qui est le rapport a été
remis de manière satisfaisante voilà il
y a eu un accueil satisfaisant c'est ce
que la seule chose que je puisse dire à
ce stade mais nous avons rempli notre
obligation et nous continuerons à la
remplir
je reviens sur la question précédente
parce que j'avais noté quelque chose que
j'ai oublié de vous dire vous nous dites
150 milliards de vues sur les vidéos
booktok sur les documents booktok 150
milliards sur combien de milliards dans
le monde
annuellement alors c'est 145 je prends
le chiffre précis voilà 145 milliards au
jour d'aujourd'hui
donc c'est ce qui est pratique j'allais
dire c'est que ces mots dièse en fait
vous pouvez les suivre en temps réel
puisque il suffit de taper le mot dièse
dans la barre de recherche et vous avez
en temps réel la popularité de tel ou
telle modies donc c'est un ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est un mouvement
que je disais spontané c'est une
initialisée une utilisatrice qui a créé
ce modi # et ensuite c'est devenu viral
et maintenant ça peut faire l'objet
effectivement de d'une plus grande
éditorialisation
si vous avez le chiffre le nombre sur
booktok vous avez sans doute le nombre
global mondial
de vue
de l'ensemble des
documents de Tik Tok
dans le monde
alors
en fait ce que cette mesure ça veut dire
qu'il y a 145 milliards de vision de
vidéos qui portent ce mot dièse en fait
c'est ça ce que ça veut dire donc comme
booktok ce sont des chroniques
littéraires on peut dire voilà il y a eu
des chroniques littéraires qui ont
circulé sur l'application et qui au
total ont été vu 145 milliards de fois
ça peut être parfois évidemment un
utilisateur qui va regarder deux fois la
même vidéo ça c'est possible aussi mais
c'est disons une une
donnée intéressante sur la popularité la
popularité d'une tendance oui et ce sont
les données publiques que vous pouvez
suivre pour le pour
témoigner de la popularité il faut le
comparer à l'ensemble oui ma question
est simple combien de vues combien de
vidéos combien de milliards de vidéos
toutes catégorie confondues sont vus par
an sur Tik Tok
oui alors je ne sais pas si cette donnée
est disponible quelque part c'est pas
comme si c'est 300 milliards quoi oui
oui
je suppose que c'est pas le cas ce qu'il
faudrait pour connaître la popularité
c'est combien par rapport à l'ensemble
des vues sur l'ensemble des vidéos vues
sur Tik Tok
tout à fait non non vous avez vous avez
raison c'est c'est l'intérêt d'ailleurs
d'avoir ces API de pouvoir aussi faire
ces travaux de quantification
en tout cas pour nous par rapport à aux
ordres de grandeur que que nous avons en
tête c'est le signe d'une grande
popularité
on peut faire l'exercice vous pouvez
vous-même faire l'exercice sur certains
modèles et on voit à quel point c'est
important là par exemple la compétition
de films qui a été faite
récemment Tik Tok short film on peut
voir qu'il y a plus de 9 milliards de
vues donc c'est c'est quelque chose
aussi de tout à fait intéressant puisque
ça n'existait pas il y a deux ans
est-ce que Tik Tok France ça quitte de
sa contribution au CNC
alors en avril 2023 donc c'est tout
récent nous avons fait notre première
déclaration au titre de la taxe sur les
services numériques
donc de ce point de vue là
nous sommes bien en règle de nos
obligations fiscales
la taxe qui ont le produit est versé au
CNC fait l'objet d'une discussion entre
les équipes fiscales qui sont donc
regroupés à Tik Tok UK et avec
l'administration fiscale française il y
a des questions qui ont été posées sur
l'assiette de la taxe par nos équipes et
donc Tik Tok est en attente de la
réponse de l'administration fiscale pour
évidemment respecter pleinement ces
obligations quand est-ce que Tik Tok
France a été créé exactement
donc c'était en 2020
donc depuis trois ans pour le moment
vous payez pas encore la contribution au
CNC et
on attend le on a le temps la réponse
surtout de l'administration fiscale qui
à ma connaissance n'a pas encore été
donnée
en juillet 2022 Tik Tok a publié un
communiqué expliquant que la société
suspendait la mise à jour de sa
politique de confidentialité qui lui
permettait de se passer du consentement
de ses utilisateurs européens pour les
exposer à la publicité ciblée
cette décision qui intervenait à la
veille de l'entrée en vigueur des
changements faisait suite à des
discussions